acknowleding
e
chair recogniz the chair recognizes a
member from Auburn represent wasburn
rules the house ajour from the session
of March 21st
2024 are you ready for the question
question all those in favor say I those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
house is adjourned the house will attend
to a Prayer by guest chapen Rabbi Daniel
Aronson of congregation ahavas aim and
King Spirit of wisdom kindness and
Justice Wellspring of life
love and
Community you who are known by many
names and are beyond all
names we ask your
blessings on the families of the six
public workers who perished in the Key
Bridge
tragedy and we join our hearts with the
people of Baltimore and
Maryland and we ask your blessings on on
the New Hampshire House of
Representatives as it adjourns to do the
people's business this
day May these legislators govern
justly disagree with
Civility and lead with
humility seeking to understand before
insisting to be
understood treating one another with the
dignity and respect they wish for
themselves remind them
that all human beings near and far are
neighbor and
sibling gay straight
transgender male
female black and white Hispanic and
Asian Muslim Jew Christian Hindu sik
Buddhist and
atheist and yes Democrat Republican and
independent let them heed the calls of
of prophets throughout the ages to
respect and protect the most vulnerable
among us our children the elderly the
poor those who are hungry those who have
no homes those who are ill in Body Mind
and Spirit the strangers and immigrants
in our midst those who live on the
margins those who are alone those who
are forgotten
Grant these elected officials the wisdom
and courage to know and do what is right
and good and true to borrow the words of
Father Greg
Bole may they strive to create a
community of kinship and an Ever
widening circle of
compassion may they abandon the idea
that there is Us and Them
for
ultimately there is only us one
Humanity only
us source of goodness we pray that the
work of their hands Prosper for the sake
of all Granite
Staters and their neighbors and siblings
everywhere and let us say
Amen
the chair recognizes a member from
Raymond representative Tim K Hill will
lead us in the pledge of
allegiance to of the United States of
America
to
stands
indiv andice for
all the chair now recognizes Jana El C
of Raymond who will sing our national
anthem can you
see by the
[Music]
dawn what so
proudly we
ha at the
Twilight last
ging who BR stripes and bright
through the
perous
fight or the real parts we watch were so
gallantly
streaming and the rocket red
glare the bombs bursting in
there gave proof through the
night that a plague was still
there oh say does that star spangled
bner yet
wave or the land of the
free and
the of the
[Applause]
bra
the house will tend to request for
leaves of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Gibbs Harley Montiel
James Murphy Finny trevan the day
important business Representatives
breard Mason sandborn true and vanney
the day illness in the family
representative
Ming these leaves will be granted unless
otherwise ordered by the house the house
will attend to the introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome Anna
buckton student from Bedford High School
our page for the
day Welcome to the New Hampshire house
Mr Speaker please welcome Christine
Kamal Ed ridus Cindy roning and Julia
moss and Steed guests of Representative
abar Brenda wolf and Sue young guests of
Representative Tim kill Tara painter and
Philip and EMT Ray Clancy guests of
Representatives Tony leus and Alicia
leus and The Honorable Melbourne Moran
former member from naswa and Lisa
Simmons Marin guests of Representative
Greg they are with us in the gallery
today
well welcome to the Min Hampshire
house the house will attend to a
memorial
resolution Mr
Speaker house resolution
34 the the house will be in order
whereas we have learned with profound
sorrow of the death of our friend and
colleague Arthur S Ellison who is
serving his third term as a state
representative representing the citizens
of marac County District 28 WS 1 2 and
three of the city of conquered and
whereas a dedicated civil servant Arthur
Ellison worked for 38 years in the
Department of Education where he made a
verifiable difference in the lives of
countless Gran
Staters and whereas art Ellison served
the entirety of his legislative career
on the house education committee where
he was known as a consumate professional
who while passionate in his beliefs and
advocacy was never disagreeable and was
a pleasure to work
with and whereas art Ellison scale at
organizing with the state employees
Association and within his caucus was
acknowledged by his appointment as an
assistant Democratic
leader and whereas above all art Ellison
was a devoted husband father and
grandfather who spoke lovingly of his
family and his joy in being in their
company as he bravely faced his illness
now therefore be it resolved by the
House of Representatives in regular
session convened Arthur S Ellison be
granted the highest praise and accolades
and our profound thanks for his service
to his state in the city he called home
for many years and be it further
resolved that expressions of our most
heartfelt sympathy be extended to his
family and that a suitable copy of this
resolution be prepared for presentation
to them
please join and rise in honor of
representative from Conquer The
Honorable a
Allison the house will now attend to a
consent calendar
chair the clerk Mr Speaker in a letter
dated March 27 2024 dear Paul please be
advised that the following
Representatives elect were sworn into
office by the governor and councel on
this day Rockingham County District
number 21 Jennifer Mandel bom of
Portsmouth straford County District
number 11 Eric Johnson of Lee sincerely
David M scanland Secretary of
State let's welcome on colleagues of the
New Hampshire
[Applause]
house the house will attend to the
consent
calendar Mr Speaker from the committee
on criminal justice and Public Safety
House Bill 1711 removed by repres
Representatives Hull Tom Manion mcarter
kushman Jonathan Smith Prout Gard Kelly
Penza and ktoa from the committee on
Transportation House Bill 1637 removed
by representative Sykes Romo plamondon
St Clair Aly foot Drew Fox Corman Gorski
and
Jones are the rening of the bills
removed from consent representative
Osman moves a consent calendar with a
relevant amendments as printed in the
day's house record be adopted are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the consent calendar is
adopted the house will now attend to the
regular
calendar majority committee on commers
and consumer affairs to which is
referred House Bill
1365 an act relative to substitution of
biological products by pharmacies
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation to Bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen Keith Ammon from the
minority of the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation the bill be referred
for interim study representative Tim M
for the minority of the committee the
amendment is
12438 printed in house Record 12 page
145 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor fa say
I I those oppose nay the eyes have it
and the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is on to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety to which was referred
House Bill 1366 FN an act relative to
penalties for the negligent or Reckless
operation of boats consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation the
bill ought to pass with Amendment s of
Terry Roy for the committee the
amendment is
011h printed in house Record 12 page 145
I you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I nay the eyes
have it and the committee report is
adopted majority of the commit on
criminal justice and Public Safety to
which was referred House Bill 1539 FN an
act relative to annulling representing
or discontinuing prosecution of certain
cannabis offenses consider the same
report the same with the recommendation
the bill ought to pass pres of Jonah
wheeler for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with a majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate pres of
johathan Smith for the minority of the
committee the chair recognizes
representative
rhods thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I
recognize my friend from peterborough's
Passion about this particular piece of
legislation and the fact of the matter
is regardless of what any of us feel
about the possibility of cannabis
becoming legal in New Hampshire it is
not as of now
legalized and this bill aims to make an
inment process basically a
blanket for anybody that may have had
prior conviction because of
cannabis we hear thousands of bills in
the
house many that will never become law
just because this subject is being
discussed does not mean that that's
going to
happen
additionally the way this bill is
written it will put the erroneous on the
New Hampshire families to be responsible
for the inment
process I find it really hard to believe
that any of us should have to pay for
someone else's analment hearing we
didn't do the
crime at the time of these
convictions cannabis was illegal and it
still
is this does not take any of that into
effect
whatsoever RSA 651 has a very defined
process for annulments that is
working my suggestion is if we want to
streamline the process if and when
cannabis becomes legal then let's put
that language into one of the Cannabis
bills not a whole separate piece of
legislation thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
wheeler thank you Mr Speaker the current
process for annulments has people paying
$300
to request a hearing to get their
conviction anold and as we discuss here
in this body the legalization and not
just legalization but sale of cannabis
where the state will be selling this
drug I and the 14 members of the
criminal justice committee who voted
ought to pass on this legislation felt
that it was an egregious wrong that we
should be discussing the legalization
and sales of cannabis while people are
stopped from getting loans or getting
jobs or moving forward in the process of
Rehabilitation because of a cannabis
conviction on their record the bill
before us HB
1539 would set up a process by which the
department of safety would observe all
the people in their records and see if
anyone meets the criteria of solely a
cannabis conviction and that would then
be eligible for an analment hearing that
doesn't guarantee that you're going to
get an analment it guarantees you a
hearing some people deserve an analment
some people might not the legislation is
very clear and I think the majority
report handles this
well nobody who has pled down from a
crime which was more than solely the
Cannabis charge is eligible for the
hearing they aren't eligible to get the
analment nobody who had gotten a
cannabis conviction above the limit
that's put forth in the bill can get
even a hearing and the bill does not say
that people are automatically eligible
for an nments it says that you're able
to get your hearing and I think uh a
fair process before the courts uh just
demonstrating that you have
rehabilitated yourself demonstrating
that you are on the process to
Rehabilitation uh showing that you want
to get a job you want to get a loan for
whatever that business that you want to
start is or the school that you want to
go to is and making sure that you can
live a full life that's what HB 1539 is
so I appreciate the passion from my
friend from the minority of the
committee on this legislation but I
would ask the house to consider the fact
it's a little hypocritical for us to be
discussing uh the
[Music]
heran thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative for taking my question it
it was stated previously that cannabis
is still illegal in New Hampshire but it
isn't it true that it's now a civil
offense and the people were talking
about having a chance to get rid of
their convictions were convicted as a of
a criminal offense and that's a major
difference in the law that's
changed that is a a great Point
representative representative Granger
has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently
seconded I will reemphasize that when I
ask for a second on a roll call you need
to be in your
seats
e
the house will be in
order the motion before us M majority
committee report of aop pass on House
Bill
1539 this is a roll call
vote the chair recognized representative
RS for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the way this bill is
written it's going to put the the
liability on the New Hampshire taxpayers
to have to be responsible for other
people's annulments and if I know at the
time that this that this was illegal and
that the law was broken would I vote no
on the aop pass
motion chair recognized representative
Nel for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that cannabis
convictions not only create harm in the
sentence but long- lasting harm and
seeking employment housing and more well
after an individual's punishment has
been completed and if I know that as a
state currently in the process of
legalizing cannabis acknowledging the
benefits including a hefty Financial
benefit should be actively seeking to
relieve the burden imposed on those
individuals harmed through throughout
the prohibition years would I now push
the green button in favor of ought to
pass the motion before us is the
majority committee report of Auto pass
House Bill 1539 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote
283 voting a 80 voting a committee
report is
adopted committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety to which was
Mr Speaker committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety to which was referred
House Bill
1713 FN an act relative to a defendant's
presence during criminal proceedings
having considered the same report the
same the following recommendation the
bill ought to
pass for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion State your motion to
table hb7
13 table table the motion is to table
house bill
17713 representant of Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently
seconded this will be a division vote
the division has been
requested
for
the motion before us is to table house
bill
17713 this is going to be a division
vote chair recognized representative H
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this forces someone who is still
innocent until proven guilty to show up
in court
prematurely if I know that this could be
used to weaponize the court process for
someone who's been accused of a crime
but not found guilty would I now vote
Yes on the table
motion chair recognize representative
Roy for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that everything the previous
speaker just said would be U made moot
by the um floor amendment that I'd love
to get to and if you care
about giving victims a chance to be
heard for their victim witness
statements would I then vote to stop
this tabling motion so that we quickly
move on and look at the floor Amendment
thank
you the motion before us is a table
house bill 17113 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
e
representative
Newman all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay the
vote 112 voting a 256 voting a tabling
motion
fails representative Roy offers floor
Amendment 1367 H it's in your seat poets
and is recognized to speak to his
Amendment thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker after filing this
bill with the honorable um speaker
ameritus um we looked at it we discussed
it with the uh various members of this
body and we heard you um it was overly
Broad and it could be used to make
someone show up if they didn't want to
as part of their defense having said
that this floor Amendment only does this
the defendant has to show up in court
for the reading of the verdict and for
the sentencing again for the reading of
the verdict and the sentencing if the
jury spends the time to hear this case
the defendant should take the time to go
in and respect that jury and hear their
verdict and he darn sure should show up
for his sentencing that's the only time
s they have to appear in court I'd ask
you to pass this amendment in the
underlying Bill thank
you the motion before us is the Roy
floor
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
I those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the floor amendment is adopted chair
recognized representative P off we're
now on the motion a to pass as
amended he's waving he's waving off
representative Roy is waving off
representative Granger had requested a
roll call on this is that sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
this will be a Voice vote the motion
before
us is ought to pass as amended on House
Bill 17113 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I iose
nay no you guys have it and the
committee report is adopted ought to
pass as
Amendment committee on education to
which was referred house bill for 1014
relative to the registration of high
school students to vote it comes to us
without
recommendation representative Hall moves
ought to pass representative cordelli
moves
Amendment 59h printed in house Record 12
Pages
44 chair recognizes representative Hall
to speak against the
amendment thank you Mr Speaker today I
rise in opposition to Amendment 1159 H
one would hope an amendment to a bill
would make it better in this case it
does not in fact it does nothing to
address the intent of House Bill 1014 to
encourage student voter registration and
Civic engagement which is a challenge
given that in the 22 midterms only
15.6% of New Hampshire 18y olds
registered to vote 15
6% this amendment includes what is
already in statute that Civics
instruction must include teaching about
the role opportunities and
responsibilities of a citizen to engage
in Civic activity the amended language
requires that election and voting laws
also be included in the Civics
curriculum which I would argue is
already included in the law how what is
problematic in is that the amendment
strikes out the entire language on voter
registration which requires each school
district and private high school to
adopt a policy with Provisions for
informing eligible students about voter
registration laws and for filing voter
registration applications it's important
to note that promoting registration is
key to encouraging young students to
vote Civics credits can be earned in
grades 9 through 12 which means that
some students are 14 or 15 years old
while enrolled in their civics class
receiving a copy of the Constitution and
being taught about voting and election
laws in ninth grade is vastly different
than three years later when students are
old enough to apply their knowledge to a
real world situation that is registering
to vote if they so
choose this amendment completely negates
the intent of House Bill 1014 to
increase New Hampshire student voter
registration and to encourage more youth
Civic engagement please vote no on this
amendment so that a better motion can be
made and Mr Speaker I ask for a division
vote thank you chair recognize
representative
cadelli thank you Mr
Speaker represent
representative
J recognized representative McDonald
thank you Mr
Speaker the bill has introduced burdens
Municipal staff mainly Town clerks and
supervisors of the checklist as well as
places mandates on struggling school
districts the amendment however removes
the burden by removing the Mandate also
the amendment addresses a number of
concerns raised by the Secretary of
State's office specifically registration
drives must be open to the public and be
accessible to the elderly people with
disabilities people with physical hand
handicaps and are otherwise medically
fragile these vulnerable populations
would be effectively disenfranchised if
House Bill t 14 were to pass as
introduced finally the amendment adds
that New Hampshire laws surrounding
voting be included in the Civics
curriculum which is under development as
a result of Senate Bill 216 being signed
into law last year therefore press the
green button to adopt the amendment
thank
you a division has been
requested members take your
seats
represent cell who would you like to do
the
Parliamentary
e
the motion before us is the amendment
1159 H this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Woodcock for a
parliamentary
inquir thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this amendment
does absolutely nothing to improve the
bill it's just a waste of taxpayers
money and if I know that the request to
add information on Election law is
already part of the curriculum in Civics
today and if I know by way of reminder
that this amendment does absolutely
nothing I wish youd vote no on the
amendment thank you chair recognize
representative penel for a parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that this
amendment clar
[Music]
represent
B all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to say the
vote 189 voting nay 186 voting nay the
amendment is adopted so the motion
before us now was ought to pass as
amended all right the motion before us
is a to pass as amended on House Bill
1014 are you ready for the
question all all those in favor say
I those oppose nay the eyes have
it
represent
L representative
lad
the committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1015 FN relative to
requirements for literacy skill
development in Elementary grades this
comes without recommendation
representative bbon moves ought to pass
in offers Amendment
116h printed in house Record 12 Pages 44
chair recogniz the representative
cascaden for speak for the
amendment thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I urge you to vote otpa on 11
706 on House Bill 1015 for what's best
for
kids House Bill 10 1015 amendment 116h
is a bipartisan bill it's amended by two
professional Educators who have many
years of experience teaching students
how to read excellent literacy
instruction builds a strong Foundation
of learning it's our Collective
responsibility to advocate for
ensure and protect these rights for
every child everywhere passage of House
Bill 1015 Amendment
116h would provide continuity and
consistency in the execution of teaching
reading to all children in our public
schools in an explicit and systematic
approach the national reading panel
considered over 10,000 studies of how
children learn to read over a period of
many years since
1966 several first selected for review
and
Analysis the national reading panel
research findings are five Essential
Elements of Reading pheic awareness
phonics fluency vocabulary and
comprehension the five components of
reading are inclusive of the various
English language arts areas and must be
implemented in a response to
intervention model that includes
screening benchmarking and progress
monitoring when the national reading
panel find findings were disseminated to
New Hampshire school districts many
engaged in implementation strategies
updated programs added instruction and
interventions in the five essential
components this dates back to
2005 sustainability of best practices
requires leadership from the top and it
must remain priority the national
reading panel's analysis made it clear
what the best approach to reading
instruction should be
last session RSA 200 colon 59 was passed
updating the requirements for Universal
evidence-based reading screening for all
students for indicators of Dyslexia and
other Related
Disorders but we've put the cart before
the horse this body needs to provide
clear policy on the what we want for all
New Hampshire students to be proficient
in literacy skills approve this bill and
this amendment to give give all public
schools the legislative leadership that
should have already occurred once
passage the message to all school
districts will be consistent and
clear this amendment is not a list of
unfunded mandates or a list of
directives it's in full support of RSA
E2 which says it is the responsibility
of local teachers administrators and
school boards to identify and Implement
a approaches best suited for the
students in their communities and to
choose the methods of instruction the
activities and the materials that they
are to
use in addition no further educator
testing is needed because it is already
required New Hampshire certification
requires already the candidates must
pass a specialized exam and that's since
2014 teachers need to take a found found
of reading test and that is if they are
becoming certified as an early childhood
educ educator an elementary education K
to 6 in elementary education K to 8 a
reading and writing teacher or a reading
and writing specialist in addition to
that reading test they must all take the
practice one of Test of Basic Skills and
the practice too which is in a Content
areas take the advice and recommend
ation from professional Educators who
have walked the walk and talked the talk
for what's best for kids Public School
Educators know teaching and learning let
them carry it
out this bill can ensure all New
Hampshire students and children are
afforded reading development and
instruction that is delivered to meet
the needs of their individual abilities
this bill leaves local control in the
hands of the districts it's sets
expectations as to what skills the state
of New Hampshire feels every student
needs to know in order to be afforded
the best chances for
Success ultimately this legislative body
should prioritize Equitable literacy
instruction by setting policy as
identified in Amendment
116h for the benefit and enhancement of
all New Hampshire Public School students
on behalf of what's best for kids I urge
you to vote yes on otpa
116h thank you Mr Speaker does member
yield the
questions yes member
yields I guess I I guess no is the
answer uh division has been requested
members take your
seats
e
go
the motion before us is the amendment
116h this is a division vote chair
recognized representative ball for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I Know That explicit systematic
phonic Bas instruction was the gold has
been the gold standard for teaching
reading since 1935 when Orton Gillingham
the grandfather of all phonics-based
reading programs introduces method for
teaching students with
dyslexia and if I know this method of
teaching the five components of reading
has been used in New Hampshire special
education classrooms well before I was
trained to be a special educator 25
years ago and if I further know that
this gold standard of explicit
systematic instruction in Reading
Writing and math could easily be
implemented in the general education
classroom to meet the needs of all
students and if I further know that the
New Hampshire Department of Education
wisely offered a professional
development program in phonics based
instruction called letters well before
the schools uh were shut down for covid
and thousands of teachers and parents
have participated ated in that
program and most importantly Mr Speaker
if I know that school districts around
our state have already begun screening
students for reading disabilities and as
we speak many school districts are
piloting phonics based reading programs
that utilize systematic explicit
systematic instruction then I would
press the green button and ensure all
New Hampshire
students all New Hampshire schools make
the move to explicit systematic
instruction and Reading Writing and math
thank
you the motion before us is the vote on
Amendment
116h this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppos you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
smart
representative
Bo while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 297 voting yay 77 voting a the
amendment
passes it bills on second reading open
to further Amendment Senator cordelli
offers floor Amendment
1314 it's in your seat
pockets
chair recognized re
cascaden thank you Mr Speaker colleagues
I urge you to vote itl on Amendment 1314
H for what's not in the best interest of
kids
a1314 is contrary to RSA 193
e2a part five lowercase a it is the
responsibility of local teachers
administrators and school scho boards to
identify and Implement approaches best
suited for the students in their
communities to acquire the skills and
knowledge included in the curriculum to
determine the scope organization and
sequence of course offerings and to
choose the methods of instruction the
activities and the materials to be used
in addition no further educator testing
is needed because it is already
required in short this amendment would
mandate another legislative prescriptive
prescription increase School costs for
personnel to provide services increase
teacher responsibilities for preparing
and documenting new individual reading
plans and replace the screening and
intervention for dyslexia and Related
Disorders legislation that just went
into effect this past September I urge
you to vote itl on amendment
134h in order to make a Statewide a
Statewide statement for what's best for
kids thank you Mr Speaker J recognized
representative
cordelli thank you Mr
Speaker
52 please remember that
number I am offering this floor
Amendment as I believe we need a
comprehensive approach to improving
literacy in this state we cannot wait
three years and not pay attention to all
pro aspects of the literacy problem in
this state this amendment is the result
of two years work with national and
state leaders it has the support of the
New Hampshire literacy leaders group
consisting of reading specialist
District liter literacy directors and
dyslexia
interventionists it all starts with how
we teach reading research has been done
for decades on the way students learn to
read and how their brains actually work
this body of research and evidence-based
research has been termed the science of
reading we must move away from the old
discredited methods in use in many
school districts in New Hampshire so
what does this amendment do first the
Department of Education will evaluate
and contract for a universal reading
screener to be used by all
districts that contract has to be in
place by next January they will also
Prov provide training on the use of that
screener the screener will do various
things including check for descrip
deficiencies in a student's reading
recommend interventions for that student
relieve teachers of data entry work and
some of these systems also included a
parent
portal there is no
mandate date for use of this screener by
the districts screen scening will be
required in K through three grades and
three times a year the current standard
is just two times a year that's not
sufficient if proficiencies are found a
of interventions will be required and I
that these screeners will automatically
recommend
strategies the Department of
Education in September is to provide
guidance to local school districts on
evidence-based resar search
instructional methods that they should
be using and then it will be the Local
District that picks the curriculum to
use local control
right parental involvement has too often
been ignored that is required in this U
Amendment parents have to be notified on
a regular basis how their child is uh
making progress and how they can help
their
child these are mandates primarily on
the department periodic workshops for
teachers and parents annual progress
reports but school districts have
accountability reports
also and what good is is this in
comprehensive approach if new teachers
are not trained properly coming out of
colleges a survey of Co of college
teacher prep programs in New Hampshire
found that three of four New Hampshire
programs scored a d or an F including
UNH the Department of Education is to
annually survey these programs to make
sure that they are moving toward the
evidence-based instruction
methods current teachers involved in
reading instructions seek certification
renewals and will be required to pass a
test to show their understanding of the
evidence-based methods beginning in 2028
this is the same test that's being given
to new teachers asking for their
certification competitive grants will be
available to school districts who have a
proficiency rate below the state
average you remember that I asked the
number to remember was
52 52 is the average State proficiency
rating in our schools today 52% 48% are
not proficient
we cannot
wait we can't continue to he hear about
mental health in schools maybe is mental
health problems are due to anxiety
because students can't properly read and
are having difficulty keeping up with
their
work this cannot
continue we need a comprehensive
approach that this amendment offers we
have to turn things around now we can't
just tell districts to move to the new
methods in three years we cannot tell
the kids to do the best you can waiting
means failure please vote green on this
amendment to provide assistance to
teachers and students to improve
literacy in New Hampshire and Mr Speaker
I request a division
vote cadelli request a division this
will be a division vote members take
your
seats
for
it's this is a
division
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1314 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative ball for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this amendment repeals the dyslexia
screening law that we just voted on last
session and went into effect act in
September
2023 and if I know that this amendment
narrowly focuses on the 48% of students
who score below Proficiency in reading
but does nothing to address the needs of
the 58% of students who scored below
Proficiency in math or the 62% of
students who scored below Proficiency in
science and if I know that children's
brains develop at different rates and it
is our curricul
that changes at third grade and not our
students brains indicating the
importance of explicit systematic uh
instruction continuing through grade
five something that is not done in this
amendment and if I further know that
this amendment places additional
unnecessary requirements on Educators
renewing their license in a time when
districts are struggling to retain
experienced Educators and Recruit new
Educators to fill job
openings and and if I further knowe that
this amendment provides no time for
districts to Pilot new programs or
budget
funds and also undermines clal control
by being too prescription too
prescriptive in its overreaching
burdensome approach to creating a
comprehensive reading plan with little
input from the local
Educators and Mr Speaker if I know I
have no idea how much this amendment
will cost the taxpayers it could be
million it could be 5 million or
potentially it could be $10 million
added to our
budget at a time when taxpayers are
already having difficulty paying their
property taxes representative this is a
pi not a
speech other household expensives then I
would press the red
button and support a more sensible
amendment that we just passed to address
New Hampshire's low proficiency scores
in Reading Writing and math
thank you chair recognize representative
lad for parliamentary
inquiry thank you and good morning Mr
Speaker if I know it is
unacceptable that 48% of our students in
this state are not proficient in
Reading if I know this amendment better
supports an EV evidence-based
comprehensive approach to teaching
reading that includes phonics phonemic
awareness
fluency vocabulary comprehension and
contains a strong assessment component
and required teacher training and if I
note Research indicates that on average
children who are taught phonics get off
to a better start and learning to read
than children who are not taught phonics
would I then press the green button
to improve Proficiency in the state and
to approve this amendment thank
you the motion before is floor Amendment
1314 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the vote
145 voting a 229 voting a the amendment
fails
the motion before us is a to pass as
amended on House Bill 1015 this is a
division vote members should be still in
your
seats
the motion before us as aut to pass as
amended this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative cordelli for a
parliamentary
inquiry
speak chair recognized representative
lad if I know that Proficiency in
Reading is drastically needed and that
this program will help do that would I
then press the green button
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 1015 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 365 voting a nine voting
a report is
adopted before we get into the next bill
I'd just like to remind members that
parliamentary inquiries are just that
they're not
speeches they need to be concise and to
the point thank
you yes the clerk has an
example Mr Speaker if I know that the
sky appears blue because blue light is
scattered more than the other colors
because it takes a shorter smaller wave
to travel and if I know this is Phenom
this phenomenon is called ra scattering
would I now vote Yes by pressing the
green
[Music]
button that's what a pi should
be the committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 108 for relative
to qualifications for the commissioner
of Education this comes without
recommendation house will be in
order for what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker I move to table HB 10884 and
I request a roll call
vote Sweeney has requested a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote on the tabling
motion
first
the motion before
us is table House Bill
1084 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Sweeney for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know the sky is a little gray today
and further Mr Speaker if I know that
the underlying bill is a targeted piece
of legislation towards a commissioner of
Education in the state would I now press
the green button so that we can lay it
on on the table thank you chair
recognize representative selig for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that there
is an amendment that has a carve out for
the current Commissioner of education
and if I know that the underlying bill
is about having the best services for
our students across the state would I
now vote no on the tabling
motion the motion before us is a table
House Bill 1084 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're opposed you'll press a
red button voting station are open for
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also attend to state of the
vote 196 voting a 179 voting a house
bill 1084 is laid on the
table
committee on education to which was
referred H Bill 1087 establishing a
commission to study information literacy
and media literacy instruction in public
schools this come to us without
recommendation chair recognizes
representative Miler for what thank you
Mr Speaker I'd like to move to table
this motion representative Miler moves
to table House Bill
1087 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I I suppose nay the
eyes have it and 1087 is laid on the
table for what reason for what reason
does a member rise thank you Mr Speaker
I move to remove hb1 1683 from the
table and ask for a roll call
vote
e
will
repres representative
Osborne moves that we take 1683 off the
table and he is requested a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your seats
e
the motion before us to REM is to remove
remove 1683 from the table this is a
roll call
vote chair recognized representative
Shapiro for a parliamentary
inqu thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that every
Health Care procedure medication or
intervention carries a degree of risk
and that it is every Granite State
stator's right to weigh benefits and
risks for themselves and Mr Speaker if I
know that eliminating Medicaid
reimbursement for infant male
circumcision will diminish Health Care
choice for New Hampshire families and
increase health care disparities for
low-income Granite
Staters and
Mr Excuse
me and Mr Speaker if I further know that
HB 1683 just one week ago in this very
same chamber was fully litigated and a
motion of otpa was defeated by 19
votes would I then push the red button
so that HB 1683 can remain on the table
where it will undoubtedly be debated
well into the
future chair recognize repent of Osborne
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that hb1 1683 is a
simple Bill to discontinued taxpayer
funding of elective irreversible genital
surgeries on babies would I now press
the green green
button the motion before us is to remove
from the table 1683 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
represent
McGuire
while members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 189 voting yay 188 voting nay and I
did vote
HB 1683 is removed from the
table the pending motion before us right
now is inexpedient to legislate
representative Osborne has asked for a
roll call that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote on the
expedient to legislate
motion
okay
speaked okay
C
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate this is a roll call vote chair
recognize representative Osborne for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
hb1 1683 is a simple Bill to discontinu
taxpayer funding of elective
irreversible genital surgeries on babies
would I now press the green
button red
button chair recognizes representative
Shiro for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that decisions about
infant male circumcision are best left
to patients and medical providers and Mr
Speaker if I know that complications do
occur and there's clearly a need for
timely and thorough education for new
parents but Mr Speaker if I also
know that the overwhelming majority of
adult males circumcised at Birth have
lived completely normal lives free of
physical mutilation psychological trauma
and circumcision related sexual problems
would I then push the green button to
support an L it
motion the motion before us is
inexpedient to legislator in House Bill
1683 if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also will attend the state of
the
vote 185 voting a 188 voting aay the itl
motion
fails
representative Tim K is
recognized thank you Mr Speaker having
voted on the prevailing side I move
reconsideration of otpa on House Bill
1683 representative K Hill moves
reconsideration on House
Bill 1683 on the ought to pass as
amended
motion are you ready for the
question all those in favor
say I'm sorry I'm I may have
lost track but did we just vote on the
itl failed okay we're reconsidering it
the
otpa okay gotcha thank you I'm I'm sorry
I just sort of lost my place in the
system there thank
you okay the motion before us is
reconsideration on ought to pass as
amended has a division has been
requested request
who representative meller request a roll
call is that officially seconded is
officially seconded this will be a roll
call
vote
okay they want to
one
okay the motion before us is to
reconsider the autop pass as amended
motion on House Bill
1683 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Osborne for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I still
know that hb1 1683 is a simple Bill to
discontinue taxpayer funding of elective
irreversible genital surgeries on babies
would I now press the green button and
maybe the next one can be a Voice vote
chair recognize represent perel for
parliamentary
anory thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
I know that this bill is not about your
personal feelings about male
circumcision and Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill will decrease choice for
New Hampshire residents and increase
healthc care disparities would I then
vote
no on reconsideration thank
you the motion before us is
reconsideration on House Bill 1683 and
the motion was autopass as amended this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
cellen
while members presentent had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 188 voting aay 186 voting nay
reconsideration
passes now we're back to ought to pass
as
amended are you ready for the
question division has been requested
members take your
seats
well I don't know who called it but it
is sufficiently
seconded
C
the motion before us is a to pass as
amended on house
bills
1683 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
here's the
situation
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 184 voting a 191 voting aay the
motion
fails for what reason does a member rise
house will be in
order Mr Speaker recognizing that
although it is not Groundhog Day we are
yet back in the same place I would move
to place House Bill 1683 on the
table the motion is to play 1683 on the
table are you
ready are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I those oppose
nay House Bill 1683 is laid on the
table
[Music]
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1093 prohibit and
mandatory the house will be in
order prohibiting mandatory Mass
policies in schools comes to us without
recommendation representative Nobel
moves ought to pass in offers floor
Amendment 0911 H printed in house Record
12 Pages 59 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I those oppose
[Music]
nay close the doors close the doors
nobody in or
out
no hold hold it this is a confirmation
vote so it's going to be a division vote
for those in the
chamber
representative
wheeler
ification
vote okay members need to be in their
seats this is a division vote on the
clarification vote that we on The Voice
vote we just had if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
will
[Music]
represent
jurus
that's
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also will attend to state of the
vote 172 voting aay 163 voting aay the
amendment is
adopted so now we're on to autop pass as
amended
and chair recognizes representative
Damon
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues I ask
you to pause for a moment step back from
the understandably strong emotions
around our shared concerns with pandemic
history and the impacts of masking so
that together we can consider the best
outcome for HB
1095 please imagine that you are an
8-year-old second grade student will
call her Lydia you've had surgery to
remove a brain tumor and are now
undergoing chemotherapy for months to
come as many of us know chemo saves
lives but also often has profound side
effects most commonly it greatly reduces
immunity which gets our little girl very
vulnerable to any contagious illness
Lydia who has always thrived in school
has not been able to attend for over a
month now her oncologist has authorized
her return to school with the
qualification that she and her
classmates routinely wear masks to
protect her from what could be a fatal
illness she is
elated yet under HB 1093 Lydia would not
be able to return too the M will suspend
for a
minute there seems to be a mass Exodus
leaving the chamber for a minute so
would everybody please respect the
speaker's right to be heard if you have
to have a conversation take it out into
Annie room if you're leaving be be quiet
please thank you member may continue
thank you Mr
Speaker under HB 1093 Lydia would not be
able to return to school because the
school district could not require her
fellow students to mask for her safety I
ask you is that fair and
reasonable as a health care professional
I know that science is constantly
evolving we make decisions with what we
know and understand at a given point
point in time the changes in
recommendations can be frustrating and
confusing that doesn't mean we shouldn't
adjust
recommendations for example a simple and
not particularly emotion Laden topic do
eggs raise cholesterol or could we
freely eat them every day over the
course of my career as a dietitian the
answer to that question changed more
than once when we finally determined
that despite being high in cholesterol
eggs do not significantly increase human
cholesterol levels it was great to share
that good news with patients during
covid the virus itself changed the rates
of infection in communities fluctuated
and experts adjusted guidance as new
knowledge became available that is the
uncomfortable but wonderful reality of
science as we keep learning our
approaches to Wellness
evolve the covid pandemic changed us our
Public Health knowledge is vastly
different than four years ago the
recommendations that led to masking in
schools throughout the pandemic were
from the best of intentions based on the
knowledge of that
time HB 1093 seeks to prohibit public
school districts from adopting enforcing
or implementing
policies requiring students of the
public to wear a mask well on school
property since none of us has a reliable
crystal ball we cannot predict our
future challenges we simply cannot know
whether it would be valuable to require
masking someday we cannot know when
Lydia and students like her will need
our reasonable decision making to
participate in the education that all
students deserve this outright ban is a
step too far we need to have flexibility
for different
circumstances we need to continue to
allow our local elected School boards
the freedom to respond to health
emergencies according to the needs of
their local community we all hope to put
the pandemic behind us and never need to
mask again yet we should maintain
flexibility for addressing our unknown
future please join me in pressing the
red button to maintain local control
over these decisions thank you chair
recogniz representative
Noble thank you Mr
Speaker as a Public School parent during
covid I remember all too well what it
was like for our kids it was a time we
would like to leave in the past but not
before taking preventative measures for
the
future school Mass mandates had a
negative impact on our children and did
not promote an environment that is
conducive to learning in a Harvard poll
conducted in March of 22 46% of parents
said maske wearing hurt their child so
social learning and interactions 39%
said it affected their child's mental
and emotional health this is consistent
with testimony that we received in
person and
online a heavy burden was placed on
children to protect adults they were
treated as if they and those around them
were perpetually sick creating a climate
of fear students were repeatedly told
that they would get their family members
sick if they didn't keep their masks up
they had to wear a mask for hours a day
in school on the bus during gym class at
recess outdoors and even while playing
instruments students with autism anxiety
asthma or learning disabilities were not
able to get exemptions from these
mandates
however under the governor's mask
mandate they would have been Exempted
his mask mandate Exempted K through2
students teachers and
staff School mask mandates originated
with school
boards finally in February of 22 the
governor said that schools would no
longer be able to mandate masks and
those that continued their mandates
would be in violation of Ed 306 rules
some had already dropped their mandates
by then but many had
not teachers and administrators also
grew weary of the Mask mandates in an
article at that time a local
superintendent said as administrators
and teachers were tired of asking kids
to continue pulling up their masks and
explain to them why it's just kind of a
mass fatigue if you will on the part of
the wearers and the people that have to
enforce the
wearing the opposition to this bill is
concerning because it means there is a
potential for this to happen again if
there's some Public Health crisis in the
future then mandates will need to come
from the state because school boards are
not qualified to make these types of
decisions this bill does not ban masks
it simply leaves it up to the most local
decision makers the families and their
students please vote yes thank you and
Mr Speaker I request a roll call
vote pres Noble has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
members need to be in their
seats
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill
1093 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative B bony for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that local school
districts are responsible for developing
policies and procedures to ensure the
safety and protection of their students
students and staff members especially
those most vulnerable to potential harm
from
infection and if I know it is impossible
to predict what health emergencies might
arise in the future and what the
recommended best practices for
prevention of infection will be and this
bill May prohibit school districts from
following State
mandates then would I now press the red
button to keep students in classrooms
and allow elected School boards the
freedom to respond to health emergencies
according to the individual needs of
their communities thank you chair
recognize representative Corell for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that some Reasonable
Doubt exists regarding the overall
effectiveness of wearing face masks
as expressed in numerous medical journal
articles and by a growing number of
medical experts if I know that face
masks have been proven by widespread
anecdotal evidence to have harmed
children emotionally and physically and
to have hindered their education during
the covid pandemic if I believe that
local school board members are not
MediCal experts and should not be
arbitrarily man mandating the wearing of
face masks would I now protect school
boards from being held liable for the
harm caused by face masks and press the
green
button the motion before us is ought to
pass an House Bill 1093 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're opposed
you'll press a red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
all members president had an opportunity
to vote how
10 have all members president had an
opportunity to vote Al will attend to
stay to the
vote 187 voting yay 184 voting a
committee
report committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 1287 FN relative
to definition of the term evidence-based
within public education comes without
Rec recommendation representative beler
moves ought to pass chair recognize
representative cascaden for a uh to
speak against the
report thank you Mr
Speaker Albert Einstein stated the
essence of science is the seeking in
whatever manner is suitable there's no
logical
path where does a hunch end and where
does evidence begin many kinds of
evidence are available to practi
practitioners to support ideas and
propositions in their work from
observation documents word of others
reason or Reflection from research of
one kind or another evidence may take
different forms and be valued
differently in different
places scientists discourse in
reflecting on methodological Traditions
is that there is generally acceptance of
no particular no correct or proper way
of generating or marshalling
evidence evidence based within public
education includes subjective and
objective
data houseb 1287 is another overreaching
unfunded mandate dictating certified
professionals on how to carry out their
work and Charles Dickens States take
nothing on its looks take everything on
evidence speaking as an educator and a
practitioner House Bill 1287 cannot
guarantee more posi academic outcomes
this bill will not have any effect or
impact on lowering budgets and it's not
even a reasonable or common sense bill
it would be impossible to carry
out please vote no on OTP so that
another motion can be um presented thank
you J recognize representative
belger thank you Mr Speaker good morning
so let me explain to you what this Bild
does with a quick analogy if we look at
the field of healthcare and we want to
learn something about whether or not
blood pressure medication is working to
reduce blood pressure we would run a
scientific study and we would want to
look for information like did it lower
blood pressure how much did it lower
blood pressure and were their side
effects but what if I said we could do
this a different way and simply just ask
the doctors do you feel like this is
working those are two pieces of evidence
but they are not equal in what they are
demonstrating to you there's no reason
that we shouldn't be doing what everyone
else is doing in in Pharmaceuticals and
elsewhere in education by relying on
good objective data and the scientific
method as far as doing scientific
research we have colleges all over this
country doing scientific research on
these methods every day we should be
using them
yet currently so much of what is done in
Education is relying on surveys they
simply send out this and they ask
questions about how people think things
are going or how they feel things are
going that's not good enough evidence if
we pass this bill what we will do is we
will require them to align it with only
objective
data by aligning it with objective data
and good science what we will do is we
will improve outcomes while
simultaneously reducing costs because
over time we're going to stop chasing so
many fads and settle on what
works please support this please press
the green button thank
you motion before us is ought to pass on
speaker represenative Belair has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded it'll be a roll call
vote
where
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 1287 this is a roll call vote
chair recognized representative luno for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
this bill is modeled on a national bill
that started in another state and is
latest effort to inject religion and
unscientific Views into the science
classroom and if I KN know it will
unleash an assault against scientific
integrity leaving students confused and
unprepared to excel in the modern
Workforce n if I know New Hampshire
students perform among the best in the
country and Mr Speaker if I know the
Moon is not made of cheese then would I
press the red button to defeat this bill
and support strong student outcomes
thank you g recognize representative
McDonald for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I
believe that words should mean what they
say they mean and if I know that
accurately defining reliable data as
evidence-base does not prohibit
self-reported data from being used but
it simply must be labeled as such and
finally if I know that teachers students
and administrators will benefit from
this legislation would I now press the
green button to support the motion thank
you motion before is a to pass anounce
Bill 1287 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your oppos you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 179 voting a 193 voting a the
motion
fails representative luno moves
inexpedient to legislate I are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I
iose nay
no the eyes have it 170 193 to
197 committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1383 relative to
Cooperative School Board District
elections this comes without
recommendation representative cordelli
moves a to pass and offers Amendment 11
123h printed in house Record 12 page 40
145 146 are you ready for the question
on the amendment all those in favor say
I I those oppos
[Applause]
nay division has been called on the
amendment only people in the room nobody
in nobody
out okay this is a clarification vote on
the
amendment if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations open for 30
seconds
representative
cordelli all members present had an
opportunity to vote El will attend to
state of the
vote 188 voting yay 187 voting nay the
amendment is adopted the chair and now
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended the chair recognizes
representative
luno thank you Mr Speaker this bill is
amended is an attempt by the state
government to interfere with private
contracts it would make changes to
articles of agreement voted on by the
members of a Cooperative School District
these agreements Define how these school
districts a portion and elect board
members and how budgets are
funded some people might like the
changes that are mandated by this bill
but most
won't this bill makes changes to these
contracts against the will of Voters
let's stand up for one of the most
fundamental principles and that's to
keep the state out of private contracts
let's vote against the motion of ought
to pass as amended thank you m Mr
Speaker
chair recognize representative
cordelli thank you Mr Speaker I'm not
sure if any of you are familiar with the
little town of Effingham New Hampshire
it's a little town of about 1700 people
in Caroll County and one of the six
towns in the governor Wentworth School
District question for you who do you
thinks who do you think elects the
Effingham representative to The
Cooperative School Board if you say
Effingham you're
wrong every voter in the school
district elects the representative from
Effingham do you think that wolfboro
residents where the high school and
middle school are should with a
population of four times that of
Effingham should control who the
Effingham representative is in a recent
election the Effingham candidate a let's
call him won won the Effingham vote but
candidate B won because of all the other
towns voting for candidate B we hear
about fairness all the time fairness in
funding for instance well how about
fairness in
representation I know that chairman lad
would probably not want all the Carol
excuse me Grafton County represent
voters voting for his seat in uh
havil this bill is about fairness it's
simply says that Effingham and every
other small town in a Cooperative School
District should elect their own
Schoolboard
representative vote for fairness vote
Green motion before us is ought to pass
as amended on House Bill
1383 division a division has been
requested members take your
seats
for
the motion be the motion before us is a
to pass as amended and House Bill 1383
this is a division vote chair
recognizing representative Tanner for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
Cooperative school districts are
complexed and vary in how they elect
their school board members based on an
area a
agreement and if I know that this bill
removes the power of each citizen of
Cooper operative school districts to
choose the best election system for this
situation by inserting a one-size
fits-all
solution and if I know in a Cooperative
school districts voters should be able
to decide how they are governed and how
they choose their school board not this
legislature would I now vote an
opposition to ought to pass with
amendment by pressing the red button
thank you chair recognize representative
lad for parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know this bill provides the
opportunity for all districts within a
Cooperative School District to elect
their own board member who is domiciled
in their district and to find no
residents in small pre-existing
districts within a Cooperative School
District often feel disenfranchised
without their voice being heard would I
then press the green button in support
of small town residents and Fair
elections thank you motion before us on
House Bill 1383 is a to pass as amended
this is a division vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppos you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
to vote also attend to stay of the vote
representative
O'Brien have all members present and an
opportunity to vote also attend to state
of the vote Y is 185 nay is 188 the
motion fails
representative luno moves interim study
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say i i n the eyes have it and
1383 is inum
studied committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 4 1452 FN
relative to credentials for the position
of superintendent of schools and school
business officer this comes without
recommendation sen of L lunam who was
ought to
pass for what reason as a member rise Mr
Speaker I move to table House Bill
1452 present Sweeney moves the table
House Bill
1452 division a division has been
requested
members take your
seats
e
the motion before us is the table H Bill
1452 this a division vote chair
recognized representative lad for a
parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know the tabling
motion is the motion would I vote
green chair recognized representative
Woodcock for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that every
superintendent of the school district is
the educational leader of the district
and if I know that there is a vast array
of evidence-based research that defines
a correlation between school leaders and
the success success of that school or
system and if I know the preparation
training experience in the field is the
most sound approach to effective
leadership organization than when I now
press the red button so that students
tax pay of New Hampshire would be better
served by central office leaders that
have credentials and experience and
education to lead the school district
than by the current fly by the CD of
pants approach please vote
R the motion before us is a table H Bill
1452 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button if
you're oppos you'll press a red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
for
all members present had an opportunity
to vote I'll attend to say the
vote 193 voting a 182 voting a 1452 late
on the
table committee on education to which
was referred house bill 14 53 relative
to degree granting authority of certain
institutions of higher education comes
without recommendation sen of luno moves
ought to pass for what reason does a
member rise Mr Speaker I move to table
hb1
1453 Senator Sweeney moves the table
House Bill
1453 division a division has been
requested members should still be in
your
seats
for
the motion before us is the table House
Bill
1453 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative lad for
Parliament
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know the state of New Hampshire
welcomes both nonprofit and for
for-profit institutions of higher
education in the state would I then vote
green chair recognize represent Woodcock
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you again Mr Speaker if I
know that nonprofit organizations
singular mission is to to fulfill the
needs of the client or the guest or the
student while for-profit organization
singular mission is to make
profit and if I know that every private
college in University of New Hampshire
currently is nonprofit and meets all
federal anti-discrimination regulations
while for-profit colleges have less
obligation to meet those same
anti-discrimination and title n
regulations then would I press the red
button and continue to support colleges
whose primary goal is education of the
student and not profit
motion before us is the table House Bill
1453 they say division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members present and an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay the
vote 190 voting aay 184 voting aay House
Bill 1453 is laid on the
table
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1476 FN relative to
scatter School charter school
memorandums of understanding this comes
to our recommendation sen of voludo
moves ought to
pass for what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker I move to table HB
1476 sen Sweeney moves to table House
Bill
1476 a division has been
requested members take your
seats
C the motion before us is to table 14
House Bill 1476 this is a division vote
chair recognized representative lad for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know a
Charter Public School and a resident
District are required to have
anou in place to ensure that students
are provided services in accordance with
IEP plans at the start of the school
year and if I know that this bill
proposes to delay theou that defines how
special education services are provided
to the Charter Public School until
November 1 2 months after the start of
school and delaying that
IEP would I then do the best thing with
the bill and that's to table it thank
you chair recognize representa B bony
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that school districts are obligated to
provide special educ ation and 504
services to identify students who reside
in their districts but attend Charter
Schools regardless of whether or not a
memorandum of understanding is in place
between the district and the charter
schools and if I know that extending the
due date for the memorandum of
understanding would be beneficial to
both the school district and the charter
school without resulting in any delay of
services to the students then I would I
now press the red button to defeat the
table thank you motion before us is the
table H Bill 1476 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppose you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representa represent
p
all members present had opportunity to
vote house will attend to stay the
vote 192 voting a 182 voting a house
bill 1476 late
table
the committee on education to which was
referred house Bill 1481 relative to
appointments to fill vacancies do at
large Cooperative Schoolboard seats
comes to us without recommendation
representative dry moves ought to pass
representative Tanner recognized to
speak against the
motion thank you Mr Speaker we're back
to Cooperative school
districts um Cooperative school
districts are formed by joining towns to
share the significant effort and cost of
providing schools educational programs
transportation and other educational
requirements they're about
31 Cooperative school districts in New
Hampshire operating in New Hampshire
Cooperative schools vary widely across
the state in size and how they
operate usually The Cooperative School
District maintains elementary schools in
separate towns and then consolidates
students for middle and high school
each district has unique and complex
articles of agreement or informal
agreements that outline shared cost
governance and
operation the cooperatives articles of
agreement set the procedures for
electing school board members and
replacing vacancies which vary from
Cooperative to Cooperative some
districts elect their Schoolboard
members at large others a com
combination of at large and from
specific towns
and or elections strictly within each
Town hb1
1481 requires a one-size fits-all
procedure for all Cooperative school
districts F filling vacant seats in the
school board the bill stipulates that
when a school board seat is vacated the
successor must be appointed from the
same municipality as the outgoing member
was at the time of their election the
amended bill will apply retro
actively to existing articles of
agreement without voter
approval finding any qualified volunteer
to fill Schoolboard seats as we know is
often difficult and time
consuming 1481 makes it harder to fill a
vacant seat by taking a local
Cooperative schools procedure that has
been working in place for this situation
and makes it more restrictive and
complex this can result in a vacant seat
that could remain empty for a
considerable time long-term vacancies on
school boards could affect the unique
circumstances each Cooperative School
Board May face when governing their
District the many issues involved with
Cooperative school districts should not
be addressed as we've seen with peac
meal and highly on it fits all
restrictive
Solutions but instead should be
addressed with a study committee to
review and recommend comprehensive
legislation that takes into
consideration the various and unique
situations of Cooperative schools and
the articles of agreement please vote r
on 1481 thank
you representative D recognized to speak
in support of the
motion thank you Mr Speaker good morning
as you just heard the number and the
composition the method of selection the
terms of the members of uh Cooperative
school boards are all provided by the
bylaws and the area agreements or the
articles of agreements that Cooperative
districts
have they vary from District to District
but just because towns are in a
Cooperative doesn't mean that they're
the same size so when a vacancy occurs
in any Cooperative board seat that's
elected at Large it's important to
maintain any balance of town or
municipality representation that might
exist on the
board the easiest way to do this is to
have the vacancy filled by a successor
who is from the same municipality as the
outgoing member this bill establishes
that requirement and I urge its passage
and Mr Speaker I ask for a division
vote the questions on the mo about to
pass on House Bill 1481 there is a
division vote members take your
seats
for
questions on the motion about to pass
anoun Bill 1481 this is a division vote
representative Cornell's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that each Cooperative school district is
unique and if I know that Cooperative
school districts each have existing
articles of agreement and if I believe
that this bill would interfere with
existing contracts without Vote or
approval which I believe they would
object to would I now press the red
button so a different recommendation may
be
made representative Nobles recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
the least restrictive means to maintain
the elected balance on a Cooperative
School Board is to replace a vacancy
with a person from the same town would I
then press the green
button the questions on the motion to V
to pass and now spell 1481 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button if you're opposed press
the red voting stations are open for 30
seconds
for
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house attended
the state of the
vote 186 in the affirmative 188 in the
negative the motion failed
representative Tanner
moves I'm sorry lunu luno moves interim
study all right then the motion is inim
study on House Bill 1481 you ready for
the question all those in favor say
I all those oppose nay no the eyes have
it and the motion's
adopted
the committee on education which is
referred House Bill 1592 fan local
relative to the use of Education Freedom
account funds in religious schools comes
to us with out
recommendation representative Miler
moves out to pass representative
cordelli is recognized to speak against
the
motion for what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker I move to table House
Bill 1592 and ask for a roll call vote
representative Sweeney moves at House
Bill 1492 be laid on the table this is a
roll call uh he requests a roll call and
it is well seconded members take your
seats
C
the motion is to table House Bill
1592 representative Damon recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry oh never mind didn't see you
there representative lad's recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know this bill would prohibit the
use of e-education Freedom account funds
from being used for tuition to religious
schools and if I know a high court the
high court held that when governments
choose to subsidize private schools they
must allow such funds to pay for
religious schools and if I know the
majority of justices believe that
excluding religious groups from
government programs is a violation of
the First Amendment free exercise clause
with Then I then support the motion of
tabling this bill by pressing the green
button thank you now representative
Damon's recognized for parliamentary
inquir
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that separation of
church and state is essential to the
freedom to safely practice the religion
of our
choice and if I know that the New
Hampshire Constitution prohibits public
taxpayer dollars from being used to
support religious schools and religious
education and has prohibited it for 240
years would I now press the red button
to vote against the table motion thank
you
the motion is to lay House Bill 1592 on
the table it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent have all members present had
an opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 191 in the affirmative 186 in the
negative House Bill 1592 is laid on on
the
table the committee on education who has
referred House Bill 1616 relative to
parental consent for student
participation in Medicaid to schools
programs comes to us without
recommendation representative cordelli
moves a to pass and offers Amendment
0716 H printed in house Record 12 on
page
165 the questions on adoption of the
amendment you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those oppose
nay the eyes have it the mo and the
Amendments
adopted now we're on to the motion of a
to pass with Amendment representative
Bal Bon is recognized speak against the
motion
thank you Mr
Speaker HB 1616 concerns the Medicaid
the New Hampshire Medicaid to school
program which allows school districts
the opportunity to be partially
reimbursed by the federal Medicaid
Program for eligible services to
students this program helps local school
districts reduce the cost of special
education services to local
taxpayers parental consent is required
for a student to participate in the
program and must be obtained prior to
the billing of Medicaid this parental
consent is typically obtained during the
IEP or 504 process during which a parent
agrees to all IEP or 504 Services as a
whole only services that are considered
medically necessary for the student to
benefit from their educational program
are eligible for reimbursement such as
some occupational therapy Physical
Therapy speech therapy and Psychological
Services HB
1616 adds another step to the process
that is currently not
required the parent will need to provide
an additional consent for Medicaid
billing for a new service even though
they have already agreed to that service
change in thep review
process this increases the cost of
administrative services and potentially
increases the cost to your local school
district if this permission is not
received and Medicaid cannot reimburse
the
school the Department of Health and
Human Services has indicated that New
Hampshire will be transitioning to a new
claiming methodology to better reflect
direct and indirect Health cost health
care costs in schools interim study
would allow the committee to look at
Medicaid to schools and other Medicaid
programs as a whole to better understand
all the issues that could be addressed
by the department or through future
legislation I urge you to vote no on the
motion of
otpa so that a new motion can be made
and Mr Speaker speaker I ask for a
division
vote representative cordelli is
recognized to speak in support of the
motion thank you Mr Speaker um I agree
with a lot of what the previous speaker
said Medicaid uh to schools uh program
provides millions of dollars of funding
to school
districts and parental consent is
required ired for the first billing for
services we think in this majority
opinion that for every new service that
is being buil the parent should have
written consent for that as well this is
parents rights the parent should know
what's going on and what services are
being provided to their children and
have the right to consent before that
new service is being build and schools
are getting money for that
service please vote for parents and
parents rights by pressing the green
button the questions on the motion of
about to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 1616 this a division was requested
this will be a division vote members
take your
seats
for
questions on the motion of ought to pass
as amended on House Bill 1616 and this
is a division vote representative Hall
is recognized for parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
would require parents to provide an
additional consent for Medicaid billing
for new service even though they had
already agreed to that service change
during the IEP review process and if I
know that this bill would result in
unnecessary paperwork and related costs
to administrative services and possibly
to local districts as well and finally
if I know that a vote to interim study
this bill would allow DHHS to look at
this program as well as other Medicaid
programs as a whole to better understand
concerns that need to be addressed would
I now press the red button so that
another motion could be made thank you
representative lad's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you very
much Mr Speaker if I know by removing
parental consent when schools bill for
Medicaid
reimbursement the parent is no longer
able to attest to service
provided question build services or
require correction if the billing is not
accurate and if I believe parental
consent and approval is necessary and
adds on an additional layer of
protections for both taxpayers and the
child would I then support the need for
parental review and parental consent
when schools bill for Medicaid
reimbursement by pressing the green
button thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the motion of a
to pass on House Bill 16 16 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
Reed
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 190 in the affirmative 187 in the
negative the motion is
adopted for what reason does a member
rise I move to take HB 1353 off the
table
representative cab moves that house bill
13503 be removed from the table and this
will be a division vote members take
your seats
e
the question is whether to remove House
Bill 1353 from the table and this is a
division vote representative Lynn is
recognized for a parliamentary parli
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that it makes no sense at all
to give any agency which has the
authority to impose disciplinary action
particularly an agency as important as a
Department of Education to not have the
authority to compel cooperation and to
get be able to get records and people to
to cooperate with their investigation
then would I press the green button to
take this U uh
bill from the table so that we can have
a debate on the merits of the Bill thank
you Mr Speaker and I ask for a division
vote yeah we're there representative
margerie Smith is recognized for
parliamentary int thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the Judiciary Committee
has struggled with this bill over two
sessions and if I know that um somewhere
between 10 and 18 members of the
Judiciary
Committee um has not seen the amendment
that is going to be
proposed and if I know that this
complete rewrite has not been
vetted um and it is too broad lacks
sufficient due process and is prone to
fishing with I
now vote no on the motion to remove this
bill from the table thank you Mr
Speaker the question is whether to
remove House Bill 1353 from the table
and this is a division vote if you are
in favor press the green button oppos
press the red voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
representative
Lon
all members present had an opportunity
to vote the house will attend to the
state of the
vote 183 in the affirmative 194 in the
negative the motion
fails the committee on education who
wish was refer to House Bill 6 1942
relative to the role of Cooperative
School District Board member
Representatives on School District
budget committees comes to us without
recommendation representative Pell moves
on to pass and representative Tanner is
recognized to speak against the
motion thank you Mr Speaker Cooperative
school districts again HB 1642 removes
the voting power of the Cooperative
School Board board member on the local
budget committee and makes it an ex
officio non voting position member will
suspend for a minute sorry I didn't mean
to make a jump I got wicked noisy in
here so if you're going somewhere please
go quietly so the member can be heard
please proceed thank
you uh this bill changes current law
which requires the budget committee to
include one member from The Cooperative
School Board as a voting member the
school board member acts as a liaison to
the budget committee providing context
and helping the committee on the
elements of the budget presented by the
school district the board member
improves cooperation and communication
between school districts and the budget
committee by being knowledgeable about
the operational and instructional needs
of the school as a full voting member of
the committee the board's members input
has much greater impact than that of an
as merely an observer
the issue of Cooperative school
districts including this bill and all
the other ones that we've had um should
be worked on with representatives from
all stakeholders including the
Cooperative school districts and
municipalities in an interim study to
better understand their needs and to
consider future
legislation remember that the
Cooperative school districts formed
together with articles of agreement
um and I urge you to vote red on this so
that a motion for interim study can be
brought forward thank
you representative peternell is
recognized to speak in support of the
motion thank you Mr Speaker House Bill
1642 removes the double voting power
from the appointed Cooperative School
District Board member on the Cooperative
School District budget committee current
law gives this appointed member a vote
on both the school board and the budget
committee if we cannot vote twice in an
election why would we give an elected
executive twice the voting power please
vote ought to pass to restore the
balance of power on your school
board the questions on the motion of a
to pass on House Bill
1642 ready for the question yeah I
thought so this will be a division vote
members take your seat
pleas
they're actually
moving
quick note we only got a couple more
before we can go to lunch but the longer
it takes people to go out and then come
back
in then lunch gets put off
longer the questions on the motion of V
to pass on as spill
1642 representative Damon recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the extensive
knowledge of a Cooperative School Board
member is valuable to the budget
committee and if I know that the
concerns addressed in this bill should
be included in a broader interim study
on the government of Cooperative school
districts as noted in previous Bill
discussions would I now press the red
button so another better motion can be
made thank you representative cordelli
is recognized for parliamentary in cour
thank you Mr speaker Mr Speaker if I
believe that you will not let me vote
twice on this bill but please correct me
if I'm wrong but if I know that Coop
school board members who were also on
the School District budget committee get
two votes on the budget what I now vote
ought to pass so that they become
nonvoting budget members and then thus
get one vote like you and me by pressing
the green button
questions on the motion of ought to pass
and House Bill 1642 and this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppose press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 185 and the affirmative 189 and the
negative the motion
fails Lun stud representative luno moves
interim study are you ready for the
question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose
nay the eyes have it and the Motions
adopted the committee on Election law to
which was referred House Bill 1091 an
act relative to the financing of
political campaigns having considered
the same report the same with the
following amendments and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with
Amendment excuse me representative
Connie Lane for the committee the
amendment is 1215 H pred on house Record
12 on pages 52 to 59 the questions on
the adoption of the amendment you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those oppose nay the eyes have
it and the Amendments adopted the bill
is on second reading and open a further
Amendment represent of Lane moves floor
Amendment 1334 H which can be found in
your seat Pockets questions on the
adoption of the amendment you ready for
the question all those in favor say
I all those oppose nay all right then
the eyes have
it and the Amendments adopted now we're
on to the main motion of a to pass with
amendments are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I all those oppos nay the eyes have it
and the Motions
adopted
the committee on Election law to which
was referred as Bill 1596 FN requiring a
disclosure of deceptive artificial
intelligence usage and political
advertising comes to us without
recommendation who moves out to pass
Paul who moves out to pass
representative Brennan Brennan
representative Brennan moves ought to
pass and offers Amendment 129h printed
on house Record 12 on pages 164 to 165
the questions on the amendment you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those oppos nay the eyes have it
and the Amendments adopted bills on
second reading and open a further
Amendment representative Brennan moves
floor Amendment 1363 H which can be
found in your seat Pockets questions on
the adoption of the amendment you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those oppos nay no the eyes have
it and the Amendments adopted now we're
on to the main motion of ought to pass
as amended are you ready for that
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion's
adopted what reasons does the member
rise uh yes Mr speaker having U having
voted on the prevailing side of House
Bill 1596 I believe we just did uh I
would ask the uh for a motion of
reconsideration urge the body to vote
no
15 representative Barry reconsideration
of House Bill
1596 you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those oppose
nay the Naes have it reconsideration
fails
Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker for what reason does
a member
R uh for a motion of reconsideration on
house spill
1091 which which one 1091 is this the
two that we just
did consideration consideration
okay okay and I urge the body to vote
against it thank
you did I do something wrong
representative L M's reconsideration of
House Bill
1091 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I all those oppose
nay the NES hav it reconsideration
fails
the majority of the committee on
environment and agriculture to which was
referred out spill 1102 FN an act
relative to the definition of animal
cruelty having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is inexp I
to legislate representative Peter Bixby
for the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative Sher DY
for the minority of the
committee what reasons does a member
rise Mr Speaker I move to table House
Bill 1102 representative Sweeney moves
at House Bill 1102 be laid on the table
ready for the
question
representative Reed has requested a roll
call and it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call Members take
your
seats
yeah
the questions where to the L House Bill
1102 on the table and this is a roll
call vote representative Sween is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know the sky looks a little less
gray than it did earlier and further Mr
Speaker if I know we can all get to our
lunch table table soon if we put this
bill on the table now would I now press
the green button thank you
representative bixby's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
we have gotten an extraordinary amount
of in of email about this bill on both
sides and if I know that it is
appropriate for our constituents to know
that we have actually heard the debates
on both sides would I oppose the tabling
motion thank you
[Music]
attend to the state of the
vote 232 in the affirmative 140 and the
negative 1102 is laid on the
table the majority of the committee on
environment agriculture to which was
referred out spill 1145 FN an act
prohibiting the private ownership of
landfills having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill to pass representative
Peter Bixby for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolve that it
is inexpedient to legislate
representative Judy Aaron from the
minority of the committee for what
reason does the member rise thank you Mr
Speaker I move to table HB 1145
represent Sweeney moves at House Bill
11:45 be laid on the table who asked
representative Weber asked for a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
the be a roll call vote members take
your
seats
the motion is whether to lay House Bill
11:45 on the table
members should be in their
seats representative Alexander you want
to sit
down
thanks representative Sweeney is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know the underlying legislation
represents a gross misuse and
mismanagement of government by taking
over and prohibiting private landfills
in the state of New Hampshire would I
now vote green to put it on the table
where this bill surely
belongs representative from Mount is
recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I knew if this was such a gross
overreach then my friends would actually
want to debate it and demonstrate that
point rather than simply dismissing it
without having to make an argument and
Mr Speaker if I know that this
legislation the underlying bill was the
unanimous recommendation of a bipartisan
bamal study committee and Mr Speaker I
if I know that this is a bill that
enjoyed bipartisan sponsorship in our
committee and that we have bipartisan
speakers lined up to speak in favor of
this bill and if I know Mr Speaker that
all of our constituents whether we live
in Kean or we live in Dalton or we live
in Rochester or Bethlehem and or
anywhere else in our state is tired of
being the place where New England dumps
its trash would I vote red so that we
can actually talk about the Bill thank
you Mr
Speaker the question is whether the lay
House Bill 1145 on the table and it's a
roll call vote if you're in favor of
tabling press the green button oppos
press the red voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
repres
partial
[Music]
represent
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 180 in the affirmative 193 in the
negative tabling
fails all
right
e
the bill is on second reading and open a
further Amendment representative Rano
moves floor Amendment 1329 H which can
be found in your seat
Pockets representative Simon is
recognized to speak in favor of the
amendment thank you Mr Speaker uh
colleagues I don't want to take up a
tremendous amount of time uh right
before lunch on this so I'll keep it
really simple uh there are speakers
behind me that will speak to the merits
of the bill itself um but from the
previous vote that you just saw the
likelihood of this bill making it
through this chamber is fairly decent um
so I would submit to you um this floor
Amendment which basically just says that
um the state and the landfill owner um
have to come to an agreement there needs
to be some conversation on that and some
agreement on what happens uh if the
landfill leaks uh due to NE negligence
or mistakes uh it is a reasonable
addition to the bill I think it's a
protection for the state uh taxpayers um
so I hope that you will um vote with me
on on that regardless of how you feel on
the underlying Bill thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the adoption of
the amendment a division vote has been
requested members take your
seats
e
the questions on the adoption of
amendment 1329 H representative Aaron is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
amendment was not discussed with me or
my committee and if I know that this was
not part of any discussion as part of
our committee hearings would I press R
to vote against this amendment thank
you representative heran is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker uh if I know that
this last minute amendment was part of
how we put together a strong bipartisan
piece of uh legislation to bring to you
all would I now press the green button
so that we can attach this amendment and
move on to the Bill thank
you the questions on the adoption of
amendment 1329 H this is a division vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
for
you
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house attend of
the state of the vote 234 and the
affirmative 125 and the negative the
Amendments
adopted now we're on to the main motion
of a to pass with Amendment
representative Aon is recognized speak
against the
motion thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker and colleagues the
premise of this bill is to ban private
ownership of landfills in New Hampshire
in order to get around the US Commerce
Clause and allow us to limit or even
eliminate the importation of outof State
trash it grandfathers in existing
landfills so there will be no impact at
all to what we already do at those
facilities anyway four of the six
landfills in the state are publicly
owned almost 50% of those landfills
landfill trash is from out of
state we only have one new landfill
permit currently being considered at the
State Department of Environmental
Services and it appears this bill just
seeks to shut that down it's not even
clear what would happen to that
permitting process if this bill were to
pass in terms of landfill capacity and
need we will likely only need one new
landfill for the next 25 to 50 years
especially as we have goals to reduce
what we place in landfills landfilling
also
is our last resort in handling Solid
Waste according to our state Solid Waste
Management
plan nine members of my committee
strongly believe that banning private
ownership of landfills in New Hampshire
in order to control the amount of out
estate
trash being placed into our landfills is
wrong our state and counties and
municipalities already have the ability
to establish landfills in our state and
have done so successfully in several
places and they currently compete
alongside privately owned landfills
these entities can already set up step
up and propose establishing a landfill
to fulfill a
need Banning the private ownership of
landfills is just not business friendly
even if a private business enters into a
contract with the state county or
municipality to operate a publicly owned
landfill but not own the land why would
a contractor want to invest millions of
dollars in infrastructure on a site that
they would eventually abandon or worse
if their contract is not renewed by the
public entity they'd have to leave it
behind they'd have to hand over all that
infrastructure to another contractor who
would then run this landfill the
contractor could also possibly walk away
from a future environmental disaster
leaving the state to hold the bag and
clean up the mess the devil certainly
would be in the details of the
contract there are many other questions
regarding state county and Municipal
ownership of landfills such as would the
government entity likely take land via
eminent domain to establish a landfill
who would have the liability for the
land if the land became contaminated or
becomes an environmental problem should
these costs along with operational costs
be borne by New Hampshire taxpayers and
what about the increase in costs and
tipping fees that are likely to occur
this would surely impact New Hampshire
taxpayers and we don't believe that this
is the right solution as it creates many
more problems and increases the costs to
New Hampshire
taxpayers considering that we already
have a bill that was passed
unanimously by our committee that caps
out State trash out of state trash by
15% in accordance with the US Commerce
Clause
so I'm pretty much going to speak to the
Republican inconsistencies in regards to
HBS oh thank you Mr Speaker sorry um I
going to speak to the Republican
inconsistencies into HB
1145 so a republican talking point that
is we can't stifle private businesses
right so I would like to remind y'all
when we were talking about passing the
bill to ban China from moaning land in
New Hampshire and I supported that so
let's say a brand new Beijing based
state-of-the-art Solid Waste Company
comes into New Hampshire buys up all the
available property then they
simultaneously put in 10 applications to
build massive landfills that have 30
plusy year life in New Hampshire right
now there is nothing stopping them from
doing so because Dees only reviews
applications and approves based upon
rules not need last year Dees told a
group of legislators I was there and
concerned New Hampshire citizens in a
meeting their job is to get the permit
applications to a yes that was
concerning for us all to hear Let remind
this body that even after St gobain
polluted the drinking water for an
entire region in southern New Hampshire
Dees approved another permit before the
company decided to close up shop that
made us all pretty upset
especially the folks that living in
marac so we were told that it was
approved because they can't look at
unrelated items outside of the
application that is staring right in
front of them our landfill pering rules
are weak and the new rules in this
process that they're undertaking are
looking to be some of the weakest in New
England and in the country so because
trash is a multi-billion Dollar business
and private companies because of federal
Clause are using New Hampshire as their
Dumping Ground to
make to make sure that they will
continue to buy property and build
landfills based upon their profit not
needs of the New Hampshire
citizens we all encourage private
businesses to build here or come to New
Hampshire to improve our economy our
communities and we want them to be good
stewards to our environment but this is
not a typical business landfills should
not be ba built based upon anything else
but need do we really want New Hampshire
to become the trash State the state is
letting private businesses Drive The
Trash Bus which is not in the best
interest for granite Staters if we do
things right with reduction Recycling
and new technology to include some
amazing amazing things that they're
doing with incineration we should only
need one landfill in The Next
Century this bill enables a public
private partnership this the only thing
that the the state owns is the land
that's it this saves the private company
time and money the private company runs
everything else the standard practice
this is actually the standard practice
everywhere in the country besides over
50% of the landfills in the entire
country are are exclusively uh public
and Maine just so you know when we're
talking about that landfill that
everybody wants to stop that's happening
up north actually has um a public
private part partnership with that same
company right across the border that is
thriving it's a 32 year old 32 year uh
32ye
contract these are not private
businesses either our private operator
landfills are from companies that are
headquartered outside of New Hampshire
they are in uh Texas and Vermont so to
wrap this up this bill enables the state
to pick a good site with good soil near
the major sources of instate generation
rather than being at the mercy of a
company in Landover over um
owner sorry who don't care about the
safety or the truck or their traffic
distance and this bill enables us to put
New Hampshire taxpayers in our trash
first HB
1145 also would not require the New
Hampshire to reduce the flow of otate
trash it merely allows us to be in the
driver's seat for us so for example
let's say we have a landfill and it's
not getting filled the State can make
those decisions to increase that
percentage at any time so in fact um we
could turn on and turn off the flow
wholly or partially as we see fit based
upon our circumstances so please join me
in passing HB 1145 so that we don't make
New Hampshire a San Sanctuary state of
trash from New England most especially
from Massachusetts it's time to put New
Hampshire trash
first
the questions on the motion of a to pass
as amended on House Bill 1145 a
representative Granger requests a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
repr
that's that's
okay
questions on the motion about to pass
this amended on house spill at 11:45 and
this is a roll call vote representative
kryon recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that HB
1145 commit it's the state to ownership
of private
operations if I also know that under
current rules the state or
municipalities already own four of six
landfills and if I also know that to
provide safe and effective landfills in
the future we should not limit options
for establishing ownership would I not
press the red button so that another
more appropriate motion can be made
thank you very much Mr Speaker
representative R's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this body has a long history of
supporting clean water and responsible
environmental measures and if I know
that this proposal establishes a
balanced relationship where the private
and public entities can work together
and if I know that over 50% of landfills
in the United States are already
publicly owned with some operated by the
same companies conducting business here
in New Hampshire if I know that at one
point in the not too distant past nearly
all the trash dumped in New Hampshire
was dumped in publicly owned
landfills also known as the town
dump and finally if I know Granite
Staters Express strong opposition to the
notion of our picturesque State being
used as a Dumping Ground for
Massachusetts then now hit the green
button to keep the trash in
Mass the questions on the motion of
about to pass as amended on the house
bill 1145 it's a roll call vote if you
are in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend the state of the vote 208 in the
affirmative 162 and the negative the
motion's
adopted the house will be in recess
until
1:45
e
Administration to which was referred
House Bill
1059 act relative to State Building Code
the considered the same report the same
with the following Amendment the
recommendation Bill ought to pass with
Amendment sen of Carol McGuire for the
committee the amendment is 0
804h printed in house Record 12 page 48
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
oppose n the eyes have it and the
amendment is
adopted bills on second reading open to
further Amendment represa MC Williams
offers floor Amendment
1300h the chair recognizes
representative MC
Williams thank you Mr
Speaker I want to address some
misinformation that you may have heard
about this amendment the challenges of
affordable housing are deeply complex
this amendment is about
commercial properties this is a
commercial energy code Amendment and it
does not affect most residential units
in the state it will affect zero single
family homes or any other residential
spaces of three stories or less this
amendment has no bearing on construction
of new residential single family homes
instead this amendment is to update the
New Hampshire commercial energy code
only from 2018 to 2021 standards there
is no mandate in the commercial energy
code to require Net Zero buildings as
part of this
update why should we adopt the 2021
commercial energy code Granite Staters
like you and me spend 95% of their time
in buildings and the majority of this
time is spent in commercial buildings
schools and workplaces
the change between the current energy
code and the 2021 commercial energy code
includes mechanical duct insulation a
tighter Vapor Barrier on exterior walls
to keep out mold and keep in humidity
and increased air changes we've studied
indoor Health in schools and found that
in New England we need to keep the
humidity levels between 40 and 60%
relative humidity to protect the Celia
in our upper respiratory tracts to ward
off colds and the flu the 2021
commercial energy code does
this indoor air quality matters for
human health and productivity there is a
compelling business case for healthy
buildings a Harvard cogg FX study found
that breathing better air is better for
cognitive function and making health
related indoor air quality improvements
leads to reduced
absenteeism better cognitive function
and better employees MIT has found
through a similar study that healthy
buildings command higher rents per
square foot and contribute over 20
billion with a B dollars in worker
productivity Nationwide the 2021
commercial energy code does this as well
we heard committee testimony that large
commercial builders in New Hampshire
support updating the commercial energy
code to 2021 we need the commercial
energy code failing to adopt the code
will be a cost shift from contractors to
building owners this will increase the
cost for building owners that occupy
buildings for taxpayers paying free
energy in Municipal and school
facilities and for commercial entities
that lease space we need this bill the
2021 commercial energy code will provide
Financial benefits to businesses
municipalities and taxpayers the United
States Department of energy and the
American Society of heating
refrigeration and air conditioning
engineers have found that the 2021
commercial energy code is coste
effective more than covering the added
construction labor and materials costs
through lower monthly energy
costs for these reasons I ask that you
please support implementing only the
commercial energy code 2021 as part of
updating all of our other building codes
in New Hampshire thank
you chair recognize your representative
Carol
McGuire
thank you Mr
Speaker U first of all this amendment
was seriously considered and rejected by
the building code review board which
consists of a panel of experts building
officials building
inspectors engineers and
Architects they thought about it and
decided it was not appropriate for New
Hampshire the amend floor Amendment also
strips out the specific New Hampshire
amendments approved by the building code
review board to the energy code which is
which means that we're getting it
straight unadulterated from uh
California and New York and the other
large
states I would like to mention that in
New Hampshire commercial includes
apartment
buildings as well as
businesses and
a commercial building is more likely to
be built by someone who plans to own it
and operate it than a single family
home those people can choose to go to
the more strict energy code no problem
it's their it's well within their
Authority and they they can choose to
implement it without putting it as a
requirement on everybody
else
the other point is that you know saves
energy saves energy costs over the life
of the building well it might if you can
pay for the for the technology and the
testing and the extra materials right
away if however you have to take out a
30-year mortgage at s 7 and a
half% you're not going to be able to pay
for the difference in cost and that is a
choice that the owner of the building
should be able to make make for him or
herself and that was what the Edna
committee considered when we unanimously
voted against adopting the energy code I
hope you will join with us and press the
red button on this amendment thank
you the motion before us is the MC
Williams for
Amendment it is sufficiently seconded
not sure like this this will be a roll
call vote on on the amendment MC
Williams Floor
Amendment
e
the house the house will be in
order the motion before us is the
McWilliams floor Amendment
1300h this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Gro for a
parliamentary
ining thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the building
construction review board didn't
outright reject the um code BEC based on
its Merit but because it took would
taken too long to look at the code
amendment by Amendment and the the
energy code in 2018 was not adopted in
full but certain amendments were
addressed excuse me and if I know that
this amendment has no bearing on
construction of new residential single
family homes or Net Zero buildings and
and if I know and I think we all know
that we spend 95% of our time in
buildings and the majority of this time
is spent in commercial buildings or
house
Chambers and that the 2021 energy code
improves interior air quality and
subsequent occum health and productivity
would I not press the green button thank
you Jer andiz representative Simon for
aary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the majority of the
building code review board rejected um
adopting the energy codes for 2021
session Mr Speaker if I know that
um it will definitely increase building
costs if we adopt them at this time when
we need to be building um a lot of
commercial buildings and also Mr Speaker
that we may not actually save money um
over the life of of the building um
because of mortgage rates and interest
uh increasing the cost um would I then
press the red button to defeat the floor
Amendment thank thank
you the motion before is the McWilliams
floor amendment
1300h is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
for
all members present have opportunity to
vote also will attend to stay to their
vote 179 voting a 192 voting nay the
amendment FS we're back to aop pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I suppose nay
no the eyes have
it committee report is
adopted majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
to which was referred House Bill 1190 FN
act relative to adopting the interstate
Social Work lure compact considered this
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative Carol
Maguire for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass pres JC Grody for the minority of
the committee for what reason does a
member rise Mr Speaker I move to table
HB
1190 the motion is a proper motion the
motion is to table house Bill
1190 are you ready for the question a
division has been requested members
should still be in your
seats
speak yeah got
you
the motion before us is to table House
Bill 1190 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Gro for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that an interstate Social Work licensing
compact is an important part of our
health care program and if I know that
the debate on this um bill is bipartisan
and I know on the minds of many in this
room would I vote against the tabling
motion by pressing the red button thank
you chair recognize representative Simon
for a
parliamentary thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that the social
compact Interstate social compact would
set up a pseudo governmental entity with
the ability and power to make rules uh
that could go into effect without the
approval of the State of New Hampshire
that we would then have to retroactively
um address um bringing up serious um
balance of power issues but I then
motion to table this
bill motion before us is to table House
Bill
1190 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent Tim
kill
represent
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 181 voting a 192 voting a the
motion fails we're back to the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate chair recognizes
representative
Shapiro
thank you Mr Speaker I'm here today to
speak against the motion of itl on House
Bill 1190 a bill that will have New
Hampshire join an interstate
occupational lure compact for social
workers what is the Social Work
compact when passed by seven states this
compact will allow licensed social
workers to practice across state lines
either through tella health or in person
a practice alternately referred to as
reciprocity or licensed
portability in other words if you are
receiving me Mental Health Services and
move from one compact state to another
you can keep your
provider if you hire a new social worker
to join your New Hampshire agency who
has a license and good standing in
Vermont or perhaps in Massachusetts no
longer will you have to wait months to
see if that person can obtain a New
Hampshire
license if both states are compact
members the new hire can report to work
the very next
day I don't think I have to convince
anybody here that we have a mental
health Workforce problem the New
Hampshire Community Behavioral Health
Association representing the 10 New
Hampshire Community Mental Health
Centers reported in January 202 for that
there are th
325 clinical vacancies across the
state most clinical positions are
Master's level practitioners and most
Master's level practitioners are social
workers a 2023 performance audit report
done by the LBA on Mental Health
Workforce licensing indicates that
portability of lure remains a major
obstacle to attracting new mental health
clinicians
while recent laws have been passed to
expedite
portability processes to do so within
oplc and the relevant boards are just
not in
place the mental health Workforce
shortage is a complicated multifaceted
problem involving inadequate funding low
salaries high levels of student loans
difficult stressful work etc etc etc I
am not going to lie to you if you pass
this bill if we join the social work
compact if a number of licensed social
workers come to practice in New
Hampshire free of bureaucratic hurdles
this will not solve the mental health
Workforce shortage here however is what
it will do first it will provide one
more useful tool to attract seasoned
licensed social workers to either
practice independently in the state or
take jobs in our many understaffed
agencies and therapy
practices second it will also have an
immediate impact on our military
families who move frequently the
Department of Defense through its
military office on Military community
and family policy is a major player in
developing and supporting Health Care
compacts across the country for these
families it means that members can keep
their providers and Social Work spouses
can obtain work without having to apply
for a license each time they
move New Hampshire has joined several
indispensable healthc care compacts
including those for phys Physicians
nurses OTS pts psychologists Mental
Health Counselors and more I know that
there are those with legitimate concerns
about finding ourselves in an
ineffective or poorly run Interstate
organization if that becomes the case we
can leave we've done this too this very
part this very body passed the law to
leave an EMT compact in
2020 so please join me in enhan ening
our response to New Hampshire's
well-documented Mental Health crisis by
pushing the red button to defeat the itl
motion so that another motion may be
made and I would ask for a division vote
chair recognizes representative Carol
McGuire oh does a member yield the
questions member does not
yield thank you Mr
Speaker I would like to mention that the
Rosy promises mentioned by the previous
speaker are just not going to happen
very soon because this is a brand new
compact none of the states that we
really want to be involved have joined
the compact like Massachusetts or
Florida or New York they're not even
considering it there are some states
considering it like Vermont and
Maine but the states that are currently
in the compact are Missouri Utah South
Dakota
which are not States we get a large
number of social workers for the other
issue is that just last year we passed a
very broad
reciprocity bill for licensing and so if
someone a social worker from another
state wants to come and work in New
Hampshire they come in show their
license from another state get their
criminal background check and of course
pay the fee and poof they have a New
Hampshire license and they are fully
capable of practicing in the
state with the compact discipline is an
issue because we could only restrict
someone's ability to practice in New
Hampshire if there were a bad actor
among the social workers they could
still practice in all the other compact
States unless and until their home state
chose to take action that's a concern
right now we can protect ourselves but
we can't protect
everybody and finally this is a very new
compact that by the this bill that that
organization has the power to buy and
sell real estate hire people set their
fees set their rules which have the
force and effective law of
course and we don't know what they are
we don't know what their fees are
planning to be we don't know how
magnificent a structure they're going to
build in uh Washington DC if it was were
to be approved but if we vote for the
compact now we're going to be stuck with
it
and you know a seat at the table may be
nice but we'd be one out of seven or
more and I can't see that our interests
are going to overpower the interests of
other states and other people
so I think that we are essentially
buying into a pig and a poke in the hope
that it will help our social work
contract our Mental Health crisis and
when we have other more reliable methods
of getting more social workers and other
mental health
professionals I hope you will join with
me in the majority of the of the
committee in voting for The itl please
press the green
button representative Sweeny has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1190 this is a
roll call vote chair recognize
representative gerod for a parliamentary
inquiry chair recognized representative
Boyd for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the purpose of Social
Work compacts facilitates the interstate
practice of regulated social workers by
improving public access to competent and
professional social work services and Mr
Speaker if I know that this compact
facilitates continuity of care and
maintaining existing patient provider
relationships the Mr Speaker would I
press the red button so that a different
motion may be made to support Social
Work compacts here in the Hampshire
thank
you chair recognize representative Simon
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that what we're voting on
today we have absolutely no idea what
we're actually voting on um it hasn't
been defined yet and Mr Speaker if I
know that um accountability in this
compact from a state level is uncertain
to the point at which if there's
malpractice in our state it's uncertain
whether or not we would oversee that
malpractice in our own courts or or that
would be handled at the federal level we
don't even know that and Mr Speaker if
we have pulled out of a compact before
in the past because it didn't work out
very well why in the world would we
enter a compact before we even know what
the compact is uh for those reasons Mr
Speaker I would ask that regardless of
your concerns about the Mental Health
crisis which we all share uh that this
isn't uh the solution to it at this time
would I press uh the red button thank
you Mr Speaker green button
sorry the motion before us is the
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legisla House Bill 1190 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
Panic
Kennedy
all members present have opportunity to
vote house vend to stay to the
vote 175 voting a 200 voting aay the
majority committee report
fails of groy moves ought to
pass are you ready for the question all
those in favor say
I oppose
nay the eyes have
it and the committee report minority
committee report is
adopted
the minority of the majority of the
committee on Executive Department's
Administration to which was referred H
Bill
1222 act relative to physician
assistance scope of practice having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with
Amendment representative Tony leas for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation of the bill be referred
for interim study of JC groy for the
minority of the committee pres of kutab
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment
okay the committee amendment is
0454 printed in house Record 12 Pages
118 and 119 the question is on the
committee Amendment all those in favor
say I I oppose nay the eyes have it the
committee amendment is adopted now it's
on second reading open to further
Amendment sen of kutab office floor
Amendment
13668 and the chair recognizes
representative
roadford speak on the
amendment
thank you Mr Speaker for allowing to
speak on this amendment before us here
uh the amendment is about in the bill to
the the underlying bill is about
mid-level practitioners healthc care
practitioners the state of New Hampshire
licenses two types of mid-level
practitioners and invariably many if not
most of us have visited one of those
their nurse practitioners and physicians
assistant while both professions demand
rigorous post-graduate education there
exists a notable discrepancy in the
administrative burdens they face despite
more academic credit hours and a larger
clinical hour requirement Pas must
engage in a written collaboration
agreement upon graduation unlike nurse
practitioners one might speculate that
this stems from nurses richer clinical
backgrounds however it's crucial to
recognize that even with years of
experience Pas remain tethered these
agreements with Physicians it's worth
noting that these agreements often are a
mere
formality with collaborating Physicians
bearing no shared liability with the Pas
they're linked to and in fact we've
heard stories of Physicians charging Pas
thousands of dollars a year to enter
into these
agreements so the amendment before us
right now today has we have an
opportunity to fix this and rectify this
in congruity and Accord our mid-level
providers the respect they deserve as
professionals that they are the proposed
amendment maintains the necessity of
collaboration between Pas and doctors
yet it introduces a pivotal change after
8,000 hours of clinical practice the
requirement for these agreements to be
written is lifted this amendment was
carefully crafted and agreed to by many
of the stakeholders involved in this Con
conversation and I want to thank my
colleagues who over the last four or
five days worked hard to to put this
together um this amendment is not just a
legislative step it's a statement of
acknowledgement and empowerment to our
health care providers and a testament to
their expertise and autonomy so I urge
you right now to lend your support to
this amendment and please vote in F
favor of the amendment and ultimately in
favor of the Bill thank you you
recognize representative
collabro
she waves off the motion before us is
the cutab floor Amendment are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I oppose nay the eyes Haven it and the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is a of pass as amended are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say
I oppose
nay the eyes have it committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on Executive
dep departments and administration to
which was referred House Bill 1271 act
relative to the conversation combination
and reorganization of boards and
advisory boards we considered the same
report the same with a recommendation of
the bill will be referred for interim
study representative JC groy for the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following Amendment and a
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen Tony leus for the
minority of the
committee the chair
recognizes representative Tony
leakas thank you than you Mr
Speaker so this bill converts a number
of the occupational licensing boards to
advisory from
regulatory the difference is that a
regulatory board has the authority to do
Ru making on licensing requirements and
to make the decisions on complaints well
an Advisory board with for an Advisory
Board The Authority is with the office
the issue is that a regulator board
consists of people working in a
profession deciding on the requirements
and adjudicating complaints against
others in the same profession who are
potentially their
competitors this is a particular problem
for professions with relatively few
lies the boards affected by this Bill
are such for such professions midwives
are the best example of this there are
33 licensed midwives in the state and
the three on the board make up almost
10% of all those
licensed there have been a number of
antitrust suits against States based on
the regulatory board form of Licensing
one made it to the Supreme Court in 2015
against South Carolina and the state and
the dental licensing board lost the case
there was a significant monetary
judgment against both the state and the
individual members of the board there
was another antitrust case against a
board of acupuncture the court found
against the acupuncture board after the
state incurred almost $350,000 in legal
fees lenses were required to pay higher
fees to cover those expenses the cost
exceeded all revenue from acupuncture
Licensing in that state higher fees are
likely to be the result in New Hampshire
since occupational licensing fees are
required to cover the costs of
Licensing the US Supreme Court held that
Professional Licensing boards compris
primarily of active Market participants
have immunity from Anti-Trust laws only
when they're actively supervised by the
state advisory licensing boards have
this immunity because although they
advise the office they do not have final
Authority regular atory boards have no
such immunity from a Harvard Law Journal
article quote Regulators are therefore
advised to be extremely careful those
who think of themselves as public
officials might find that they are sadly
mistaken all the more sadly to the
extent that they find themselves having
to pay out-of-pocket damages for their
reg to their regulatory victims over
five states have passed legislation
similar to this bill since the US
Supreme Court case other states have not
used uh regulatory boards even prior to
that both the problem and the solution
are well understood there is nothing to
study this is an active area of
litigation and it's likely only a matter
of time before New Hampshire licensing
board is sued and loses please join me
in acting now and vote red to overturn
the interim study recommendation so
another motion can be made thank
you chair recogniz representative
short
thank you Mr
Speaker while the majority of Edna
committee appreciated the heavy work
done on the minority Amendment we still
do not feel it is ready for passage and
so we are recommending further study
this bill was requested by the office of
professional Li Insurance certification
oplc for several stated
reasons first that so many of the boards
comprise so few members of a given
profession that members who serve on the
boards would be liable to antitrust
lawsuits and charges of conflict of
interest as has happened in one other
state that we know of and to avoid such
liability the state needs to have more
oversight no such suit has happened in
New Hampshire but following the lead of
six other states it was recommended that
many of these boards should be repealed
combined or made
advisory we were also told that many
board meetings had not been held because
many of the professions could not supply
enough board
members during the full Committee
hearing we heard from several of the
professions that they opposed the bill
and refuted the reasoning behind it
because while meetings were suspended
during the pandemic and were slow to
resume they are getting back to normal
since then some also did not agree with
the argument of two few members causing
liability or
conflicts and we are still hearing from
many members opposing the minority
Amendment for example The
acupuncturists Who according to figures
provided by
oplc have 190 lenses and met six times
in
2023 the septic evaluators with 141
lenses met four times last year and
nursing home administrators with 167
licenses met nine times last
year yes some of the boards in the
amendment are small and did have few or
no meetings but the three I just listed
are still included in the
amendment also included in the amendment
is the guardian at Liam board which
opposed the bill stating that they are
currently quasi
judicial two members appointed by the
court five members appointed by the
governor and two
legislators the amendment changing it to
advisory pairs it down to an acceptable
five members however with one member
appointed by the court and the other
four nominated by the involved groups
but appointed by the executive director
of
oplc how does that give the state more
oversight oplc was originally created to
provide centralized efficient clerical
assistance to the various Professional
Licensing and Regulatory boards in the
state now that most of these boards have
been unfolded into
OPC that office has grown its presence
to include in many cases setting license
fees drafting rules investigating
complaints and even Prosecuting
disciplinary
cases our committee often deals with
disputes over decisions regarding scope
of practice educational standards and
who should determine these
items we have tried to maintain the the
rights of those in a particular
profession to control those areas and
while the majority of the committee
agreed with making some of the boards in
the minority Amendment advisory we heard
loud and clear that some others still in
it need further
examination be assured that we will work
on this to craft a better product so
please allow us to get this right by
voting yes on the interim study motion
thank
you representative Sweeney is requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote members take your
seats
e
for
the motion before
us refer for interim study House Bill
1271 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Carol McGuire
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr speaker if I know
that this B this amendment has
been worked on extensively by not only
the Edna committee and the
oplc but also by members of most of the
boards and if I know that the
amendment that we have presented answers
the questions and concerns of nearly all
the boards and they have they have
agreed to it and if the issue isues that
were raised at the public hearing for
the initial bill have for the most part
been
solved would I not press the red button
so a another motion can be made chair
recognize representative goalie for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that some
boards may be better off as advisory due
to their smaller size and inability to
meet but Mr Speaker if I know that a
number of the boards in this bill do not
meet this
criteria that we have heard
of such as the boards of acupuncture the
Board of Nursing Home administrators and
the board of septic system
evaluators and Mr Speaker if I know the
majority of the Edna committee believes
a thorough review of the boards needs to
be done to determine which board should
be changed to advisory through an intrum
study then Mr Speaker would I support
the majority of the committee by pushing
the green
button the motion before us is refer for
interim study on House Bill 1271 this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
referred House Bill 1545 relative the
disposal state surpress property for
affordable housing representative mag py
offers a to
pass for what reason a member rise Mr
Speaker I move to table HB 1545 and I
request a roll call
vote proper motion representative
Sweeney has requested a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote on the tabling motion of
House Bill
1545 members take your seats it's a roll
call vote
repres
e
motion before us is the table HS Bill
1545 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Carol Maguire
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the Housing Authority already has
first right of refusal on any surplus
property to be used
for affordable housing and if I know
that the definition of market value is
always a bit
subjective and if I know that there's no
need to to issue an unspecified subsidy
to housing without legislative oversight
would I now press the green button and
table this bill chair recognize of groy
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the New Hampshire Housing
Authority had a say in this bill and
actually wrote this bill with and
supported the bill because they feel
that nonprofit organizations that work
with affordable housing should have an
opportunity to purchase s Surplus land
for New Hampshire from New
Hampshire and I think that the debate
and the and the discussions are worthy
of our ears because this is an issue Mr
speaker that has been on our radar for a
long time and we need to address it
thank
you motion before us is the table House
Bill 1545 this the roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're oppos you'll press a
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote El will attend to state of the vote
190 voting aay 185 voting a 1545 is B on
the
table majority committee on finance to
which was referred House Bill 1279 FN
local act relative to payment by the
state of a portion of retirement system
contributions of political subdivision
employers considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate and of Ken Wier from the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass pres of Chuck grassy from the
minority of the
committee for what reason do a member
rise Mr Speaker I move to cable hb1 1279
and I request a roll call
vote proper motion representative Sweeny
has requested a roll call is that
officially seconded it is officially
seconded this will be a roll call
vote
I
the motion before us is a table House
Bill
1279 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative wer for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that when the state stopped
contributing the 35% to the municipal
employer cost of retirement in 2012
that we made up the loss by increasing
the employees contribution which would
be proportional to the increase of
employees and their pay the 35% that we
looked at in 2012 was this is a tabling
motion
not then would I now be in favor of
tabling this as unnecessary because we
have worked out a way to do it thank you
press the green button
house will be in
order J recognized representative grai
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this was a promise that
was made to communities back in
1967 to get communities to join into the
retirement system in the state of New
Hampshire and if I know that this is an
important
bill for all our communities whether
they be Democratic or Republican
council members Board of alderman
Selectmen if I know that they want this
bill to help relieve the burden on
taxpayers but I now push push the red
button so a further Mo motion could be
made the motion before us is the table
House Bill
1279 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button if
you oppos you press a red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
for
all members present I opportunity to
vote house will attendance stay of the
vote 182 voting a 192 voting nay tabling
motion
fails chair recognizes representative
Edgar
thank you Mr
Speaker she was I had two different
versions of this I glad I get get to
give one of them
anyway but uh yeah my my name is Mike
Edgar and uh this bill here is is really
for the city and towns um you know we we
uh we had a retirement system back in
the 60s it was like four different ones
and then they State wanted to combin
into one and uh the towns and cities
agree but
but at the same time when the uh State
convinced the cities and towns to do it
they promis to subsidize or pay for 40%
of what the
employer in this case the cities and
towns would have to pay well eventually
that got decreased but I want to remind
everybody this is for the teachers the
police the
firefighters those are the ones that are
getting uh getting the retirement which
they're paying quite a bit for because
it was increased as it was mentioned
earlier what they're paying is is quite
a bit
so basically we had it where the state
was going to contribute 40% and then
basically get down to 2011 where they
pay
zero uh my goodness but the uh I first
became involved with this with uh the
former uh representative from Hampton
reny Cushing uh was bringing this up he
was always trying to get
basically to stop the downshifting and
to get the cities and towns what what's
do them and this is one of the ones that
he really uh he was really aid about and
then uh one of my best uh memories of
this this whole topic which we discussed
several times is when our uh fighting
leprechaun brought this up two years ago
and we actually got it passed in the
house uh Michael Bryan did a great job
and I think that was uh that was really
something to
see so the uh it's eventally mentioned
that uh property uh tax relief this bill
was criticized because it had the words
property tax relief in it and I guess it
must be a popular term
because a bill that was put in by the
other
side they Ed the same term property tax
relief but what they did was they
changed it so that there was only one
year of it and that was in 22 2022 and
it was great between the towns and the
cities they got about uh 28 million back
but it's interesting that it also
getting that through it also had a uh
business tax relief in it that was part
of that bill that was put in with it for
the one
year
but so the
uh basically the state reneg on their uh
their promise and towns could really
really use the
money so I hope that the people can uh
see to actually approve this basically
won't be to approve the final bill after
we we change it but vote
red on the
itl and as I say uh yat vote
red you recognize representative Dan
Maguire
thank you Mr Speaker this is a perennial
bill and we had the identical Bill last
year in house bill 50 when that bill
came to the finance committee um we
chose to redirect it for the same
purpose but not as an immediate payment
to to
municipalities but as a pay down to the
unfunded
liability of the pension system that's a
slow way and steady way of improving the
pension system over the long Hall rather
than a shot in the arm uh for this
year's
municipalities so um that's what we
that's what we passed it was passed by a
very strong vote on the house floor we
put it into the
budget unfortunately it was ripped out
by the our friends on the other side of
the
wall um and because we did not go to a
committee of conference that was the end
of it for last year it's something that
in a committee of conference we would
have argued for
strongly this year earlier this year we
repurposed House Bill 436 to be exactly
that the exact same thing this bill as
modified to pay down the UN funded
liability that bill is now on the other
side of the wall and they have not yet
acted on it I have high you know I've
already spoken to them about it I have
high hopes that that it may um go
forward in some form the problem is we
have already given them a very heavy
lift on the general fund uh this year we
have a much more important bill that
we've already sent to um enhance group
two liability
features and we have House Bill 436
which is the pay down of the unfunded
liability if we add to it essentially
the same bill in this bill that's yet
another big chunk of the general funds
and I think it will cause them to um to
not pass
our other important bills which we have
already sent them you know it'll be just
a too heavy of a lift um for their
finance committee and it as it would be
for ours so please let's honor the
decision that this body has already
made and um give our um our attention
and our Force to lowering the unfunded
liability that helps every one every
municipality the state in the long run
which is important thank you Mr
Speaker request a roll
call has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call
vote
e
the motion before us a majority
committer report of inexpedient to
legislate this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative grassy for a
parliamentary
inquiry M thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that back in 1967 the
state of New Hampshire promised
communities a 40% share if they brought
if they join the retirement system and
if I know that in a strange quirk in
2011 this house and the legislative body
removed that contribution and it became
a zero uh support for the
communities and if I know that what goes
on on the other side of the wall is
their business and what happens on this
side of the wall is our
business and that this bill will be back
again if we do not do this this year
because our city councils our Board of
Alderman our selectman have requested
this year after year after year this is
nonpartisan if I know that this s and a
half% will make up for that will
basically bring back some of that
promise that we had for our communities
and help reduce
taxes would I now push the red button so
that we can get to Art to pass and move
this forward chair recognized
representative
wer thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
in 2012 the lack of money going to the
municipalities for the retirement
contribution was made up by the task of
making the employees pay the
difference that system has been stable
for 13 years and the employees are still
paying about less than half of what the
employer pays so if that system has been
going on for 13 years why suddenly is
there a travail about its effect on
taxes and finally if I know that the
Constitution Bill of Rights for New
Hampshire in article 36 says pensions
will never be paid for more than one
year will I please stop hearing about
broken promises plus the green button to
balance budgets thank
you the motion before us majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legisl and House Bill 1279 this a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent Alis
tur represent
go
represo all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 178 voting yay 194 voting
nay motion fails grass representative
grassy moves ought to pass
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I
iose
nay the eyes have it by 194 to
178 for what reason does a member rise
uh to make a motion house will be in
order actually I'd like to ask that the
the remarks from the last bill be
entered into the permanent Journal
please without
objection committee on finance to which
was referred House Bill 1323 FNA act
making an appropriation for the printing
costs of the New Hampshire state
constitution having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation of the bill
ought to pass with Amendment sen of Ken
Wier for the committee the amendment is
909h printed in house Record 12 Pages
140 through
141 the motion is on the amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it the amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is aut to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs to which was
referred House Bill 1280 relative to
form consent and parental rights comes
to us without
recommendation representative mlan moves
ought to pass chair
recognizes representative Bill
Palmer
thank you Mr
Speaker I rise in opposition to HB 1280
informed consent is a critical aspect of
patient care and is integral to the
physicians's code of context
ethics however this bill would put into
New Hampshire's statute informed consent
procedures and patient rights that are
already in federal requirements through
CMS which which establishes consent
standards and provides enforcement
mechanisms there are also accrediting
bodies that dictate consent policies and
we also have informed consent
requirements in New Hampshire law RSA
15132 therefore hb280 is unnecessary at
best this law could create additional
regulations and possibly conflicts with
federal laws and rules already in an
already heavily regulated area of
medicine the patient rights Provisions
in this bill seem already to be covered
in New Hampshire's Bill of Rights RSA
15121 most Physicians I've spoken to are
concerned that this would add more
administrative burden and would take
time from direct patient care and agree
that we should not codify medical
practice this is an area where we should
align with national standards and not
make practice in New Hampshire more of a
Minefield I already spend more time
learning new rules in EMR operations and
less and less time to update my actual
medical knowledge if practice in New
Hampshire becomes harder than in
surrounding states we will likely lose
Physicians to those
States finally I proposed I proposed
interim study in the HS h chess
committee because it was not clear to me
that there was a significant
problem that needed remediation and that
we want Health Providers to be able to
control how they meet current consent
guidelines and not have a oniz fits all
approached etched into law please oppose
the OTP so we can move to interim study
and find out if there's a real problem
that warrants making a new law thank
you
chair recognize represent
mlan thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker hb280 statutorily defines
informed consent and patients rights in
the context of a doctor patient
relationship and the language of the
bill draws directly from the AMA
guidelines and codifies the minimum the
minimum best practices in the delivery
of healthc care as a result many on the
Health and Human Services committee felt
that this was a very light lift and it
result in a very mild burden for those
working in the health care sector now as
if to reinforce that position the
opposing committee report stated that
and I quote the bill would put in the
statute inform Consin procedures and
patient rights that are already stand
standard practice in New Hampshire and
in the nation so already standard
practice apparently the two sides on
this bill already agreed on some stuff
and and that's a good beginning that I
can work with but where the two sides
differed was on the need to put these
practices into statute the opposing side
felt that while the language is in line
with ideal Medical Practice things like
assessing a patient ability to
understand their treatment is an
immeasurable burden that will increase
liability concerns and cast a shadow on
recruitment to the medical profession if
it was passed into
law and this is where I personally
separate myself from the other side in
my opinion there can be no true consent
without understanding and the
requirement to assess a patient's
ability to understand is fundamental
there can be no consent without it but
this bill isn't needed because doctors
don't want to provide informed consent
or good followup care the fact is that
those who enter into the medical field
have always been some of the most caring
and dedicated Professionals in the whole
of our society of course they want to
provide these things to their patients
and they're not the problem no the bill
is needed because in the last 30 years
an enormous administrative
infrastructure has grown up around
healthc care that wants to turn
everything into a process and then lean
it out and my friends that that can work
with a lot of things but one of the
things it can't work with is a
conversation between a doctor and a
patient and the final result of this
approach is that the best practices that
both sides agree upon are often being
executed in a perfunctory manner in
order to just check a box and that's not
only strangling patients it's strangling
doctors as well and there needs to be a
break on it so as such this bill is
actually a tool for patients to demand
more than a perfunctory review and for
doctors to push back against an
Administration that might have lost
sight of the core mission that they
serve so the opponents of the bill will
say they're always looking to improve
consent and as such there's no need to
put these practices in the statute well
okay but the question is how well has
that been working and to me the answer
is not very well the fact is that while
there are plenty of incent Ines for
patients and doctors to seek reform
those incentives just don't carry over
to the administrative elements of the
Health Care system so I really think
we're just now at a place where we need
to have an external statutory bump if
you truly want to shift the
trajectory so everyone in this Hall has
been a patient at one time or another so
I want all of you who are old enough to
think on this look back on the
conversations relationships and the
follow-up care that you had 30 years ago
and compare it to the kind of
relationships and discussions that
you're having today and if you think
it's better now then by all means feel
free to oppose this bill but if you feel
like me that we're losing something
really important in healthcare as we
perpetually try to lean it out I hope
you'll join with me in supporting this
Bill thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 1280 who requested
the roll
callman pres kishman request the roll
call is that's officially seconded is
officially seconded this will be a roll
call vote members take your
seats
e
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 1280 this is a roll call vote
chair recognize representative Weber for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr speaker Mr Speaker
if I know in those dear dead nostalgic
days I asked my health care provider one
question and his answer to me was if you
want me to teach you medicine my fee is
a million dollars a
minute and if I know we've progressed a
long way since
then but if I know that this bill does
not promote greater understanding it
just adds to the process and the
paperwork and therefore takes away from
patient
care and if I know that informed consent
is not a oniz fits
all uh operation because every process
is different and requires a different
sort of
explanation would I now press the red
button so a different motion could be
made thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize represent mlan for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the requirements laid out
in hp1 1280 are pulled directly from the
American Medical association's
guidelines for best practice and if I
noted in the last few decades a huge
administrative infrastructure has grown
up around Healthcare that needs to be
addressed if we want to see these best
practices carried out in fact and not
just on paper and if I know that this
bill gives the needed statutory push to
shift the health care sector into
greater alignment with these practices
would I now press the green button to
show my
support the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 1280 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose you
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
grman
all members president an opportunity to
vote also tend to stay the
vote 189 voting
a0 181 voting aay committee report is
adopted what reason do a member rise uh
having voted on the prevailing side I
move reconsideration of House Bill
1279 and urge my colleagues to vote no I
request a division vote thanks Mr
Speaker
e
the motion before us is to reconsider
House Bill 1279 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
per
leg all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 179 voting a 194 voting aay the
motion
fails committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs to which
was referred House Bill 1568 FN relative
to Medicaid reimbursement for
non-transport emergency medical service
calls this comes without recommendation
representative we Weber moves ought to
pass chair recognizes representative
Lon she wants to
wave
this will be a division vote this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
the motion before us is a to pass on
House Bill 1568 this is a division vote
chair recognize representative Lon for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill deals with Medicaid
reimbursement for non-transport if I
know that a more complete bill will soon
be in our committee and if I know the
concern around um lift assist calls will
be able to H be handled specifically at
that point would I then vote against the
OTP motion by pressing the red button
chair recognize representative
Weber thank you Mr Speaker and as has
been said here before if I know that
what happens in other places is their
business but this is our business and
this is a simple bill that simply
requires reimbursement for actual
medical
services offered by EMTs and if I know
that the result of passing the bill for
benid reimbursement will be a benefit to
our EMT services and our town taxpayers
would I now now vote green on the o to
pass to preserve all of our options so
we'll have everything to consider as we
go forward thank
you motion before is a to pass on House
Bill 1568 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppos you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote also will attend to
stay to the vote
237 voting a 136 voting a the committee
report is
adopted
for what reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker I move to lay house bill
16007 on the
table oh I'm
sorry
the majority of the committee on Health
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was referred House Bill 16007 an
act relative to expanded Safe Haven
protections having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study representative Lucy Webber from
the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being aable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Jim
kofalt for the minority of the commit
for what reason does the member
rise now the member Rises for a motion
to lay the bill on the table
representative Weber moves at House Bill
16007 be laid on the table you ready for
the
[Music]
question representative hle request a
roll call and it's well seconded this
will be a roll
call
she
the question is whether to lay house
bill 16007 on the table and this is a
roll call vote representative Weber's
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that everybody wants
babies to be safe and
cherished and if I know
that the numerous questions raised by
this
bill include the problem of leaving a 61
day period in which a child might be
abused and then because of changes in
the laws of
evidence that
abuse might never be addressed either
civil or
criminally would I now press green on
the tabling motion and we'll go to work
for this in the
future representative Pell's recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that our 20-year-old
Safe Haven law is in dire need of
updating if I know that with the
increased use of illegal drugs that we
are likely to see more and more babies
surrendered if we do not surrender those
babies
safely they may end up dead somewhere as
we have seen in the past if I know that
evidence can be obtained in ways other
than the surrender of the child and that
the New Hampshire Association of
criminal defense attorneys supports this
bill if I know that this bill has
bipartisan sponsorship and committee
support and that saving a baby's life
should take precedence over Prosecuting
a struggling mother would I please press
the red button to not table this bill so
that another motion can be
made the questions where the L House
Bill 1607 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button oppose press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
e
[Music]
mother does not want or cannot handle
the responsibility of raising this
child she would welcome an opportunity
to anonymously wash her hands of the
baby and surrender it to someone
else some parents who surrender their
infants may be heroic but this woman is
no hero she wants to surrender the baby
for one
reason because it would be in her own
self-interest to be free of this
child but it is ultimately in the best
interest of the baby to allow an option
of anonymous
surrender Danielle doofan surrendered
her baby to a New Hampshire hospital in
2021 instead of keeping Doan's identity
Anonymous that hospital reported her to
the police which led directly to her
arrest for a separate murder charge and
a Litany of other crimes in other words
New Hampshire's Safe Haven law was used
as a law enforcement
tool we need to update our safe haven
law so mothers know that they can
surrender their baby free from fear of
arrest if a mother realizes that by
safely surrendering her baby the
hospital will report her identity to the
police who then pursue and investigate
her she may not come forward to
surrender her
baby instead she might keep the baby out
of fear of
arrest what will happen to the
baby we know what will
happen as long as our safe havens are
used as a tool of law enforcement to
catch criminal parents then that baby
might die be neglected or like Doan's
first child live a short life of
unspeakable abuse
there is a critical difference between
babies and our other
constituents there is a critical
difference between this issue and most
of the issues we consider in this
house a helpless baby canot drive to
another state with better safe haven
laws only we can give parents every
incentive to save these
babies this bill will expand expand the
age window in which parents can
surrender their child and allow the
optional construction of baby boxes to
better protect infants and the anonymity
of their
parents as the New Hampshire Association
of criminal defense attorneys has
explained this is no different from
other areas where we restrict the tools
that law enforcement can
use our laws exclude evidence obtained
from illegal searches but this does not
mean we want criminals to go free
it means the police must use other tools
not illegal searches to catch those
criminals in the same way police must
use other tools to catch
criminals besides baby safe
havens what is more
critical punishing
criminals or saving babies
lives your most vulnerable and innocent
constituents need you if if you have
concerns with this bill help us continue
the conversation and let them be
addressed on the other side of the wall
speak for those who cannot speak for
themselves and join us in protecting
them by pressing the red button to
overturn the motion for interim
study representative Weber's recognized
to speak for the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker so you've heard heard a number
of most excellent points in favor of
this
bill and I understand all of those
arguments and I agree with them but
there's another side as well so let's
look at the
bill currently anybody can surrender a
baby within five days of birth by giving
a warm handoff to a hospital EMT fire
fire station police station a church
whatever the bill would change that to
61 days for
surrender and it
has the anonymous use of the baby
box as a protection and an
incentive for the parent to surrender
the child anonymous ly and I understand
all of those
arguments but here is the other side of
the
[Music]
question oh and and the third thing is
that of course it limits the liability
to prosecution either civil or
criminally for acting under the
act so here's the other side of the
question first
off somebody who is so
deep in the depths of addiction or
poverty or mental
illness that they
are considering surrendering a baby may
not even know that this law exists may
not know it's available to
them and may not be organized enough to
take advantage of the
law and that is a
tragedy
[Music]
of these devices who made it very clear
that he was making it his mission in
life to change all the laws in all the
states and yes there's nothing that
requires that his devices be used but
he's the only person who's doing it at
the
moment finally there is that thorny
issue of
liability if this bill
passes there is the very very real
possibility that
someone not
necessarily the
mother could be abusing a
child for 60
days and then could possibly put that
comos and battered infant into a box and
Escape criminal prosecution
and imagine the howls from our
constituents if that
happens there is a great deal to admire
about this
legislation uh there's a great deal to
be worked on in this
legislation so I would urge you to
support the interim study so we can
continue to work on the bill and bring
back a better product with more more of
those questions resolved thank you does
a member yield for a
question no member does not
yield okay all right the question is the
majority committee report of interim
study on House Bill
16007 this will be a division vote
members take your
seats representative whole request a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is this will be a roll call vote
still take your
seats
e
the questions on the report of interim
study on House Bill
16007 the house should be in
order this is a roll call vote
representative me is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry
hello representative masers recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that safe haven box
are being used in 16 other states and
that we want to lead New England in
child
protections and if I know that evidence
can be obtained in ways other than from
the surrender of the child and that the
New Hampshire Association of criminal
defense law supports the
bill and I also know that there was no
manufacturer at the hearing because I
was there and they were not doing an
infomercial and lastly if I know this
bill has bipartisan sponsorship and
committee
support and that saving a baby's life
should take precedence over
Prosecuting a struggling
mother would I please press the red
button to over term the interim study so
a better motion can be made thank
you representative Weber recognized for
parli
inquiry if thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that we all want to
protect
infants and if I
know the house will be in order look I
know I let a lot of stuff slide but just
for once can remember who we are where
we are and give the subject matter the
gravity it deserves please
continue thank you Mr
Speaker and if I know that I want to
protect a suffering mother or
parent but I don't want to protect an
abusive
person and if I know that you can't have
it both ways you can't say that this
bill will allow people to go free and
clear so they of course will adopt this
procedure and also argue that they can
also be uh brought to answer for their
actions in other
ways would I now vote green to support
the interim study so we can resolve the
questions and bring back a better Bill
next time around thank
you questions on the committee report of
interim study on House Bill 1607 it's a
roll call vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppos press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
for
have all members had an opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 182 in the affirmative 189 and
negative the motion
fails
representative kofalt moves out to pass
on House Bill
16007 representative cordelli moves
floor Amendment 1351 H which can be
found in your seat
Pockets representative Pell's recognized
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that floor Amendment
1351 H oh you can just talk it doesn't
have to be a
pi what a relief um thank you Mr
Speaker Amendment 1351 H simply
adds
I
don't sorry at the beginning of uh it
simply adds a list of findings at the
beginning of the amendment and also
changes the name of the safe haven baby
box to a safe haven baby just to a baby
box it can be any device it is not
Incorporated it is not patented it is
not trademarked we could machine
manufacture them right here in New
Hampshire if we needed to thank
you the questions on the adoption of the
amendment you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those pose
nay
no the eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted
all right now the question is on the
main motion of to pass as amended
representative Seth Kings recognized to
speak against the
motion thank you Mr Speaker friends I
have something very important to say
here this bill um I really like the
majority of this bill I like the baby
boxes I liked the increasing the number
of days and that had bipartisan support
the main problem is with a very small
section of the bill which is referred to
as the exclusionary clause and what this
does is it allows individuals to abuse
including sexually abusing children for
up to 61 days drop them off and have a
get out of jail free card that is a
bridge too far for me okay and when I
brought this up in commit committee we
had enough support including on the
Republican side to say you know what
that's also a bridge too far from me as
well that's why we originally supported
the interim study
bill the problem is in the last minute
leadership has decided to switch around
and say no we want to fight for the bill
completely let me ask you a
question if somebody kidnapped a child
right now and the child was missing for
three weeks would the police ever come
out on the media and say you know what
just bring back the child we don't care
what you've done to it in the last 3
weeks we will let you off scottf free
would we would we ever do that no they
wouldn't they would never do that we
will prosecute you to the fullest extent
of the law we cannot tolerate child
abusers and the problem is that if you
ever were to say something like this you
would give it would be a Clarion call to
all of the wouldbe abusers out there all
you have to do is bring back the
child and we'll let you off Scot Freak
No matter what you've done to it so what
I recommend is to not support the OTP
it's very unfortunate because uh me and
some other Representatives worked very
hard with the authors of the bill and we
said hey let's have a compromise here
I'm perfectly fine we were perfectly
fine with saying look if you're drug
addicted then we're not going to come
after you all right I've been against
the War on Drugs my entire life I don't
want a drug addicted mother to Fe to be
afraid of dropping off her baby and then
getting busted that that is not what I
want but if you are sexually abused
losing children if you are breaking
their bones and brutalizing them we will
come after you with the fullest extent
of the law we cannot tolerate that and
the problem is this sends the wrong
message and we're going to send a
Clarion call to everybody out there who
is a wouldbe abuser you have 61 days
matter of fact there was a bit there was
a um there just a couple of days ago
there was a mother who was found uh who
was busted for pimping out her newborn
child to sexual predators there is real
evil in the world people will take
advantage of this and I don't want my
hands on this bill at all so I would say
please send the bill back let's fix that
we need some compromise we can't just
have a we cannot just have a
free-for-all that is unacceptable and as
a republican that's just embarrassing
thank
you representa Pell's recognized speak
in support of the
motion thank you Mr
Speaker this bill provides a requirement
that within 24 hours of receiving a
report the department shall request law
enforcement officials to investigate the
incident including by using the National
Crime information center database to
determine if the child is missing and as
for the exclusionary rule this uses the
Fourth Amendment under the Fourth
Amendment criminal investigations cannot
directly result from an illegal search
the exclusionary rule prevents the
government from using most evidence
gathered in violation of the United
States Constitution for example the
decision in Miranda versus a Arizona
established that the exclusionary rule
applies to improperly elicited self-
incriminatory statements and to evidence
gained in situations where the
government violated the defendant 6th
Amendment right to councel some of these
individuals should be investigated or
imprisoned but should not be um
discouraged from Legally abandoning
their babies remember this is about
saving the babies not Prosecuting the
parents find them some other way arrests
due to the safe haven drop off has led
to a decrease in abandonments and an
increase in abandoned infant
death the questions on the motion of
ought to pass
as what reason does a member ask
question for the
speaker is section five now that we've
adopted this amendment something that
can be separated Ed it out so that we
pass sections 1 through 4 and section
6 yes this
divisible then Mr Speaker I would
move to divide the the amendment that we
adopted removing section five and pass
sections one through four and
six okay so the question is shall
section five be
divided the question is shall section
five be
divided are you ready for the
question rubs and have holes recognized
to what
okay the clerk has recognized to explain
the
motion Mr Speaker the question is shall
the vi the bill be divided what that
would mean is SE section five that
representative whole is asking to be
divided means that we would vote on them
separately if you vote Yes to divide it
so sections 1 through 4 and section six
would be a standalone motion and then
subsequently a division uh
if the division is successful then
section five would be voted on
separately so they would be you can you
can adopt one without adopting the other
to be clear you cannot table one or the
other because that tables the whole
bill so the first question is whether or
not you want to divide are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oos
nay keep the doors closed let's do a
division
vote yeah don't let any other other
members in this is for
clarification the question is whether to
divide section
five if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds represent Ryan T thumbs up or
down please we're
voting
[Music]
representative G representative G thank
you representative
AAR represent
maner represent D
Simone
all right have all members present had
an opportunity to vote Al lieuten the
state of the
vote 290 in the affirmative 82 in the
negative the question shall be
divided
all righty now the question is shall
sections 1- 4 and six be
adopted are you ready for the question
this will be a division
vote if anybody is outside they're
allowed to Comm in
though repr Drive request a roll call
and it's sufficiently seconded it'll be
a roll call vote members take your
seats
the question is shall we adopt sections
1 through 4 and six this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor of that press
the green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all right have all members present had
an opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote what they you ask to be excused you
were excused for the rest of the day
sorry give me your thumbs up or down
please thank you
all good now all
righty 372 in the affirmative and 1 nay
the motion's
adopted question is now shall we adopt
section the question now is shall we
adopt section five are you ready for the
question represent
we all right pres dve request a roll
call that's sufficiently seconded let's
do another roll call vote members take
your
seats
all
right the question is whether to adopt
section five representative perinel is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know that section five
is the most important part of this bill
that without the exclusionary rule
parents are going to dump their babies
in dumpsters kill them on the side of
the road let them suffocate in couches
be
order if I
know that without this exclusionary rule
the bill has no teeth would I now vote
green the question is whether to adopt
section five this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house attend to
the state of the
vote 185 in the affirmative 188 in the
negative the motion
fails without objection the clerk is
authorized to renumber the bill
accordingly
so the house will be in order
majority of the committee on Municipal
and County government to which was
referred House Bill 11 181 act relative
to Solid Waste districts considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation the bill
ought to pass with Amendment s of Jim
magy for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being enable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment joshell for the minority of
the
committee the majority amendment is
1054 printed in house Record 12 Pages
115 the chair recognize of
Representative
Oella thank you Mr Speaker I raise today
in staunch opposition to the proposed
amendment which my humble opinion
uh possesses a grave threat to the
financial responsibility we are
entrusted to uphold this amendment and
its ambiguous language grants waste
districts to exceed their budgets
without adequate checks and balances by
permitting overspending in circumstances
as vague as unusual circumstances arise
furthermore it's essential to highlight
that the proposed amendment actually
references the existing
solution uh to to unforeseen expenses
which are not
emergencies and that uh provided under
current law which is a contingency fund
waste districts already have access to
these funds uh of of the creation of a
fund um to address these unexpected
costs that fall outside of the scope of
their budget allocations instead of
creating this vague language waste
District should be encouraged to utilize
the contingency fund when faced with
usual circumstances that are not true
emergencies as representatives of the
people is our solemn duty to ensure the
transparency and accountability and
government spending allow waste
districts to bypass the municipality's
refusal to pay increased costs and seek
a recourse through the Department of
Revenue under the guise of unusual
circumstances undermines the very
principles of the fiscal Prudence that
our constituents rely on upon us to
uphold we owe that that hard we owe it
to hardworking taxpayers at the New
Hampshire uh of New Hampshire to reject
this amendment and instead pursue
solutions that prior prioritize
financial responsibility while
addressing legitimate
emergencies in a measured and
transparent manner I implore my esteemed
colleagues to stand firm on their
commitment to responsible government and
vote against this ill-conceived
amendment and wait for the next
Amendment which does not have this vague
language in it thank
you
G recognized representative a for
speak thank you Mr
Speaker uh to understand what what's
going on here you have to understand
what a solid waste district is solid
waste districts are What towns and
communities have joined together to to
form to take care of landfills to take
care of transfer stations to take care
of the Waste Services in their
communities these districts contract
with waste disposal sites like the
incinerators with landfills sometimes
they own landfills like the annhurst and
uh up in the the uh in Coos County and
they cannot just stop operating when
things happen where they might have to
blow their budget during covid this came
really close for a couple of them I know
it did and if it hadn't been for arpa
funds and for towns that could help make
up the deficit some of these places
would have had to stop collecting trash
they would have had to stop accepting
material into landfills
the language in this bill comes directly
from the language that already exists
for school districts and municipalities
it is a last
resort if you can't if you if things
happen and you can't keep functioning if
the world conspires against you there
are catastrophes that you can't control
you can't just stop operating you can't
stop you can't freeze your budget and
shut down the landfill you can't freeze
your budget and stop taking trash at the
transfer station these are problems all
this bill does is borrows language
that's already existing in two places in
the in the in the
law it's important it is critical to
continue these operations and it's it's
something that hasn't happened it's just
a last resort it's a fail safe it's
something that during
covid Solid Waste District said what
would happen if that's all this is is a
what would happen if there would be no
Last Resort like Community like
municipalities and and school districts
have in order to access this These
funds they would have to have already
have a reserve fund and most of them do
because they manage landfills they have
to handle the engineering and the
compliance they have to have something
set aside for that so they already have
access to this money they don't have
access to to your tax dollars they don't
have access to the town contingency
funds they're not part of the Town
they're a separate political entity they
own land they can incur debt they can do
everything the municipality can do
without the
municipality they are their own
political
entity so this stuff this this is really
critical if Co happens again and the
towns can't help make up the
deficit what are we supposed to do with
a trash where does it
go this is a fail safe this isn't
something that happens every day this is
isn't permission for them to blow their
budgets this is
just you know the world is falling apart
there are you know geopolitical problems
China shut down recycling a few years
ago that caused a lot of problems
because we rely on Revenue to take care
of these from those Commodities so that
put us in a in a tight spot so this is
just a last resort there are a couple
other pieces of this that are just
common sense
management um I hope you can support
this bill it is important Solid Waste
districts are important they do a lot
for our communities they help us save us
a lot of money on on disposal and help
preserve the lives of our landfills and
our disposal facilities thank you Mr
Speaker
the motion before us is amendment
1054 division a division has been
requested members take your
seats guess
they
second
e
members take your
seats
the motion before us is floor amendment
is amendment
1054 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative ellaa for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that there is a better Amendment coming
after this and that if I know that the
uh sorry okay if I know that uh the uh
the vague language in this amendment is
not necessary then would I now hit the
red button thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
Au for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
Solid Waste districts are an important
part of our community and municipality
management system and that this
amendment is important would I now press
the green button to to pass the
committee Amendment thank
you the motion before us is majority
committee Amendment 1054 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button you're oppos OS
your press the word button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
repr
p
represent while memb is president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to state to the
vote 223 voting A36 voting a the
majority of amendment is adopted bills
on second reading open to further
Amendment representative yella moves
Amendment
1048 H printed in house Record 12 page
114 chair recognized representative V
so
this quite simp wait a minute you're not
out
yet thank you Mr Speaker uh this
amendment coming up removes 2third of
this bill and all the critical parts
that make this
bill important
to Solid Waste districts
um everything you just voted on would be
removed I I hope that you uh can see fit
to keep the amendment intact by
defeating this amendment please vote
no thank you Mr Speaker chair recognize
representative M thank you Mr Speaker so
this amendment uh removes the vague
language and removes uh those
contingencies that the previous speaker
said oh we don't really need it unless
there's a a pandemic or something like
like that this actually addresses the
real issue which is that if there was a
big producer of waste inside of the
waste district and they need to direct
instead of just accept that uh waste
that they are allowed to do so so I hope
you would uh uh vote in favor of this
amendment thank
youis representative Weber has requested
a division this will be a division vote
members take your
seats
e
the motion before us is the minority
committee Amendment 1048 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppos
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had the opport heing
to vote household tend to say to the
vote 149 voting a 216 voting a the
amendment
fails now we're back to autop pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted
this majority committee on Municipal and
County government to which was referred
House Bill
1223 an act relative to governing body
members of the budget committee having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation Bill ought to pass with
Amendment representative Lorie St is for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legis
joshu CIF for the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise I'd like to make a motion to table
State your motion to table yes the
motion motion to table is in
order motion before us now is to table
House Bill
1223 a division has been requested
members take your
seats
e
you
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
1223 this is a division vote share
recognized representative aella for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the committee Amendment
um brought by concerned citizens
regarding gaming
establishment
uh is it is uh just a effort to ban uh
gaming across the state and if I know
that rushing the enactment of the
amendment without proper vetting through
more familiarity uh with the committee
with more familiarity than uh in gaming
licenses like Ways and Means uh is not
appropriate if I know that with a
moratorium with additional gaming
licenses currently in place and an
opportunity to refer the matter to an
appropri committee that there is no
immediate urgency allowing thorough
examination and consideration of the
broader implications would I vote green
thank you Mr Speaker J recognize
representative stavis for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that there was nothing rushed at all
about our committee's consider
consideration of this bill if I know the
communities across the state deserve and
are entitled to enabling legislation to
determine whe whether they want casinos
in their Community or not would I now
press the red button to vote against
this tabling motion so that the proper
debate on this thoroughly vetted vill
can be brought forward thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
table House Bill 1223 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
well
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 166 voting a 196 voting aay tabling
motion fails
we are now back to the committee
Amendment 1
218h printed in house Record 12 Pages 19
to
120 chair recognize
representative uh
roadford
thank you Mr Speaker first let me tell
you about this amendment about what it's
not because there's some confusion out
there about what this does so first of
all this amendment is not about gambling
it's not a gambling it doesn't have to
do with gambling
licenses it's not an unprecedented
action what we're going to be debating
right now it's something that has been
done and is is in law
now it's not a revenue generating bill
and it's not an expenditure bill this is
has nothing to do with with funds this
bill will not hurt New Hampshire
Charities and the timing of this bill is
not
bad so the Genesis of this and I
understand it was a non-gain amendment
that came uh came through um Municipal
and County committee but the Genesis
stems from a request made by some of my
constituents to our town officials for a
local option vote
on casino gambling you see seven years
several years ago our town voted to
permit Kino operators and my
constituents assumed the same local
option applied to other games of chance
so this winter they approached the the
the planning board and the zoning board
and much to everyone's surprise when
they checked the law the the local
option did not was not did didn't stand
for casino gambling so they had it for
we have it for Kino
gambling but they don't have it for
casino gambling so much like a zoning
ordinance a local option empowers a
community to determine what is best for
them for their Community recognizing
that these facilities entail
considerable investment millions of
dollars to build these the amendment
we're talking about includes safeguards
to ensure that current operators and
approved future operators are not
blindsided by any changes and the state
will not pull the rug out from somebody
who's made a considerable investment
into these
communities the timing of this bill this
enabling bill is crucial because there's
a specific gaming moratorium in New
Hampshire that's set to expire and the
status of some of the other moratorium
bills that are being debated right now
is uncertain
so ensuring the effectiveness of this
bill by July 1st 2024 when the current
moratorium
expires is essential for our responsible
consideration of our New Hampshire
cities and
towns so moreover this I want to point
out is a bipartisan Bill the the vote is
bipartisan it came out with a 15-5
majority one of the most important parts
of this is this amendment has received
the the approval of the New Hampshire
charitable gaming operators so all the
ATT parties involved in this are in
agreement
um they in and the charitable gaming
operators Association are committed to
being good neighbors and want the
communities where they operate to feel
comfortable with their facilities and
their businesses so in essence HB 1223
and the amendment that we're talking
about today is about empowering local
communities to make decisions that align
with their values and needs while also
providing stability and support for
gaming operators it's a balanced
approach that merits our
support and you can bet I'm going to hit
the green
button for those that of you left in the
chamber snacks have been delivered out
in the anti
room and they will be replenished when
they run out and just a reminder there
was no food or drink in the chamber
chair recognized representative
yella thank you Mr
Speaker I just want to address one of
the things that was just said and that
is that this is a local option it
doesn't change anything it's just
allowing municipalities to choose that's
wrong it's just wrong that right now if
a if a municipality allows gaming in
their
zoning cuz that's how it's currently
regulated by the by the towns if they
currently allow
it the passage of this negates that it's
automatically disallowed in the entire
State congratulations it's not a local
option you're saying not only is it
banned in the entire state if you want
the gaming establishment you have to
pass a specific Warren article saying
that it is allowed that is that is
dictated inside of the
statute so no no town has currently done
that because they're allowed to regulate
it through zoning now what we have is a
situation where someone didn't regulate
it out of out of their Town through
zoning and are complaining that they
didn't regulate It Out by zoning and now
they want a Statewide ban and you
your municipalities will have to come
back and say okay now we're going to
allow it and it's going into effect
right away it's not giving you time to
you know say like hey I want to make
this
uh uh warrant article on my next ballot
no it's it's banned right away before
the voters H and your local municipality
have had the Cho choice or opportunity
to ever vote on it for that reason alone
it's not a local option
it's a mandate and you should vote
against it thank you Mr
Speaker chair recogniz David
paig thank you Mr
Speaker so my constituents like my
colleague from littleton's have
considered the question of whether to
allow Kino in the town of Conway in fact
we've done it five times and each time
the question has come before the voters
in my town they've rejected it
soundly most recently just last year
more than
75% of my constituents voted down yet
another Warren article to allow Kino
it's a striking and consistent message
from the town's
people and yet
paradoxically my constituents finds eles
facing a situation where the decision as
to whether or not our town should host a
casino is out of our
hands it's
absurd the idea that while we can
repeatedly exercise our statutory right
to refuse Kino we have no say in whether
a casino sets up shop in our
backyard and this in congruity is what
we seek to fix with this bill today
and contrary to what the last speaker
said we can't wind back the clock in
towns like mine where the ship has
already
sailed we are going to have a
casino but this bill will ensure that
other
towns maybe your
town are given the courtesy of a choice
that my constituents never received no
that's just
this is not an anti-gambling
bill it's about fundamental principles
of local governance it's about giving
communities like mine like yours that
courtesy of a choice this bill just
extends to casinos the same local option
we have for Kino through the waren
article
process in small towns across New
Hampshire in places like Conway and
Littleton we seen firsthand the
frustration of our constituents when
they realize with shock what little
control they have over such a
significant
decision a decision sometimes affecting
the very character of the heart of their
downtown this bill offers a solution and
I'm pleased that the gaming industry
came to the table in this process and
worked with the sponsors and committee
ensuring an approach that is fair and
reasonable for oper
operators this bill doesn't jeopardize
operators existing Investments it simply
ensures that in the
future the decision to move forward will
be made with the input and consent of
host
communities with the current moratorium
set to expire imminently we need to act
decisively now to ensure that towns
across New Hampshire are guaranteed this
choice that they
deserve please join me in supporting the
amendment thank
you a division has been requested
members take your
seats
be
the motion the motion before us is Flor
Amendment 1
18h this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Vell for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this is an outright ban and
overriding of municipalities local
zoning as far as uh gaming and if I know
that this is direct ly brought by a
municipality that their Charter says
that gaming is an inherent evil and that
if I know that this is uh really should
be uh not a nerain Amendment and should
and because of the uh uh the moratorium
should just be filed like a regular Bill
and go through the the regular process
would I now vote red on this uh
Amendment thank you Mr Speaker J
recognized representative Len tur for
for
parliamentary thank you Mr Speaker if I
know this bill would add language to our
rsas for games of chance similar to the
existing language in our rsas for
casinos uh for Kino if I also know that
the bipartisan sponsors worked in
concert with the charity Casino
operators and have agreed to the
language that is before you if I know
that this is not an anti-gambling bill
but it is a bill about local control and
has zero effect on revenues but I now
press the green button to support the
motion of
otpa and in agreement with the 15-5
committee vote on this Bill thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
autop pass motion on the
amendment the amendment is 1
218h this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations open for
seconds
[Music]
represent
to all members president opportunity to
vote how attendance State the
vote 282 voting aay 86 voting nay
the amendment passes motion before us
now is ought to pass as amended are you
ready for the question all those in
favor who who who was it representative
Yeller requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently
seconded we are back
to the question are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose
a guys have it and the committee report
is
adopted we have a majority
Amendment
yeah majority Committee on Public Work
and highways to which was referred the
house will be in
order an act relative to the state
10-year Transportation Improvement plan
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment
recommendation Bill a to pass with
Amendment representative mark theoni
from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved as
inexpedient to legislate Senor Bill Boyd
for the minority of the committee
majority committee amendment is
0961 H printed in house Record 12 Pages
170 through 171 are you ready for the
question on the majority Amendment all
those in favor say I I those suppose
nay eyes have it and majority committee
amendment is adopted the bill is on
second reading open to further Amendment
Senate Boyd offers floor Amendment 1269
H and recognize to speak to his
Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker and Mr Speaker
through you to my esteemed colleagues of
the New Hampshire General Court arise in
support of my floor amendment to House
Bill 2024 the state 10-year plan which
seeks to keep Continental Boulevard in
the hands of the state I refer my right
honorable colleagues to my minority port
and to the minority Amendment which can
be found on page 171 of the amendment
calendar two years ago I stood here in
the well of Representatives Hall making
the case as to why the state should
retain ownership of Continental
Boulevard and today I return and those
same facts remain as the Roads
Maintenance piece excuse me roads
maintenance maintenance price tag gets a
little
bigger the town of meramac has never
owned this
road the state of the the State's
Department of transp
ation built this 2.5 mile stretch of
road in
1993 through eminent do eminent domain
proceedings over the ejections of the
town the prevailing argument made by the
do at that moment in time that public
necessity for the use of private
property for this road was needed by the
public in the region for greater good
some 30 years later Continental
Boulevard serves as the primary arterial
connection from route 101a to the F ever
Turnpike the road handles over 177,000
Vehicles daily as it feeds Westbound and
eastbound traffic along 101a to exit 10
and 11 on the Fe Everett in marac away
from overburdening exit 7 in
nashwa these traffic valume volumes also
exceed the urban compact section of
Daniel Webster Highway in meramac that
road handles Les approximately 15,000
Vehicles daily in my
town now the dot contends that this
stretch of roadway is no longer a public
necessity to the state and it seeks to
abdicate its ownership and
responsibility from a roadway it richly
wanted back in
1993 the town's absorption of this
roadway to our town budget will be an
additional $500,000 annually with
long-term capital costs exceeding $7
million over the next 20
years
furthermore the town could be acquiring
a roadway from the do that is currently
scheduled by them for a facelift next
year the town's projected cost for
repaving this 2.5 Mile Stretch of
roadway lands just shy of $2 million a
single cost that exceeds the town's
yearly Paving
budget as you deliberate this floor
Amendment please consider this fact
the state's AB abdication of Continental
Boulevard to the town of meramac will be
a lynchpin in how the dot handles other
state roadways in New Hampshire that
they don't want to maintain and pay the
mission creep of giving up State
roadways for cost efficiencies would
begin and it could happen in your
community auxiliary roadways like 11a
and Guilford and Alton 12a in sui and
alad portions of 101a in Milford and
Mastro 114a in gtown to name a few the
list will become endless if we remove
the Lynch pin and vote to approve the
transfer of Continental Boulevard to the
town of marac if you agree with me then
please press the green button to approve
the floor Amendment and ensure that dot
remains committed and engaged to
maintaining the roads and the highways
it has been entrusted to oversee thank
you Mr Speaker and I ask for a division
vote does the member yield to questions
absolutely
M yield representative Q you may
inquire thank you Mr speaker thank you
representative Boyd for taking my
question so if I understand correctly if
we support this floor Amendment we'll
prevent the unfunded mandate to marac
and we'll stop the dangerous precedent
that could happen to any
town thank you for the question
representative mchu and that's correct
it would stop the unfunded mandate um
that is uh elucidated in part one
Article 28 of our constitution where the
state shall not mandate or assign any
new responsibilities to any political
subdivisions in such a way as to
necessitate additional local
expenditures for what reason do the
member
rise I'd like to ask a question of the
representative does the member yield to
a further question I yield you may
inquire thank you Mr Speaker
representative thank you for taking my
question this is regarding the do
construction on Route 101a at penu
Square would you believe that if the
state didn't think that Continental
Boulevard had a regional impact to
traffic flows along Route
101a then they wouldn't be proposing to
widen that stretch of roadway there a
project that is currently
underway I thank the gentle lady for the
question and yes I would believe because
I know that the dot met with the town of
marac last week to discuss the prospects
of the construction in penak square a
construction project that has been in
the 10-year plan previously to the T to5
million and includes widening
sewer amongst other amenities to improve
that particular
roadway J recognize representative
rung
thank you Mr Speaker and thanks to my
esteemed colleague from miramac for
bringing forth this floor Amendment for
years misinformation has infiltrated the
debate about miramac tolls and now about
Continental Boulevard which has led to
some bad decisions handing over
ownership of Continental Boulevard to
marac from the state would be a bad
decision so allow me to set the record
straight decades ago against the wishes
of the town of marac which you've heard
the state built Continental Boulevard to
connect to 101a and the Everett Turnpike
both state roads it was so important to
the state to have this connection that
they took many Properties by imminent
domain and cut through school district
property leaving the Thorton's
Elementary School on one side of the
road and what could have been playing
fields for the school on the other other
their their overs salting of this road
caused the contamination of public well
that forced our water municipality to
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
to replace now after all this cost that
miramac has had to absorb and lost
property tax revenues from the imminent
domain the state wants our property
taxpayers to make up for their lost
Revenue also decades ago the town agreed
to a to on Exit 11 to pay for the
construction of a ramp to serve the
digital Equipment Corporation campus
which is now Fidelity
Investments That toll was to remain up
until the bond the construction bond for
the ramp was paid for however do has
refinanced that Bond at least twice for
other purposes even though the actual
ramp construction costs were paid many
years ago so so it was only fair for
that toll to come down so let's look at
the majority report that is on page 35
of today of this week's calendar it
states over the past several years due
to the decrease in traffic volume and
the elimination of toll plazas Turnpike
Revenue has declined considerably based
on declining Turnpike revenues and other
historical reasons the majority
committee Amendment calls for the
transfer of ownership of Continental
Boulevard to the town of
marac why should local property
taxpayers shoulder the cost of declining
Turnpike
Revenue turnpikes by definition are paid
for by
users however the first third of the
Everett Turnpike and the most traveled
section is from the Massachusetts state
line to Exit 8 this stretch has never
had a toll despite an earlier 10year
Transportation plan that called for one
along with extensive improvements which
were comp which were already
completed so new ramps Road widening a
bridge to connect to the bridge that
goes to Hudson and toll infrastructure
was constructed if this toll station was
put into operation as was planned in
that 10-year Transportation study that
Revenue would be more than enough to
cover the turnpike costs but the users
of that stretch of Turnpike have paid
nothing zero zilch
NADA it is so unfair to have one town
pay so the majority of users on a
Turnpike don't have to please vote green
to pass this amendment thank
you chair recognize her up sen
mcari thank you Mr Speaker and esteem
colleagues while you are not accustomed
to seeing the chair of Public Works and
highways in the well there's a very good
reason for
that and in our committee there is not a
partisan bone in our Collective body we
work together reason among ourselves and
nearly always reach a unanimous decision
that results with our bills on the
consent
Bill Public Works and highways has two
charges on the even years we bring
forward the 10-year Transportation plan
and on the odd year we provide the state
capital budget
before you today is House Bill
2024 and the only point of contention is
floor Amendment
1269 to stop the reclassification of
Continental Boulevard in the town of
aramac from becoming a town maintained
road to defend the committee's p
position I will offer a bit of
background for your
consideration while the turnpike system
receives limited federal funds it is
primarily funded through the toll
Revenue nearly 30 years ago the town of
meramac requested the turnpike to
construct ramps to provide access for
its citizens to the turnpike system to
alleviate traffic on Route three and to
enable development in the areas
surrounding the
ramps the turnpike system did not have
adequate funds to construct the access
in order to advance the projects meramac
agreed that the ramps would be
told Continental Boulevard was
constructed as part of exit 10
Interchange to support major
developments in the area and provide
construction to both exit 10 Industrial
Drive and Exit 11 via Continental
Boulevard both exit 10 and 11 were
told but over time the town advocated
for the removal of tolls from exit 10 11
and
12 resulting in a loss of nearly $1.6
million a year in revenue and it cost
the turnpike when they were removed $2.2
million to remove those tolls
insult to injury Continental Boulevard
is not even connected to the turnpike
but cost the turnpike
$96,000 annually to maintain Continental
Boulevard that only benefits
marabac the turnpike cannot afford this
expense without without offsetting
Revenue the overwhelming majority of our
Public Works and highways committee
18-1 supports House Bill
2024 as amended without the boid floor
Amendment
1269 I ask that you support our
committee position oppose this amendment
and press the red bet red button when
the speaker calls for the vote thank
you the motion before us is the boy
floor Amendment
are you ready for the
question did I hear a
division this will be a division
vote members take your
seats
e
the house will be in order
the motion before us is the boy floor
Amendment 1269 H this is going to be a
division vote chair recognizes Senator
Murphy to do a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the Department of
Transportation seeks to make up for a
deep a drop in toll Revenue by
reclassifying Continental Boulevard and
dumping ownership obligation and
responsibility onto the town of
miramac and if I know that the committee
Amendment violates the Constitution Bill
of Rights Article 28a creating the
mother of all unfunded mandates that
will unjustly increase property taxes
for marac residents who will become
responsible for maintenance costs such
as the $1.8 million anticipated cost for
repaving this road a sum that will
exceed the entire Paving budget for the
town and finally if I know that the New
Hampshire M municipalities like mine and
potentially yours at some point in the
future should not be mandated to take on
do resp responsibilities for state-owned
roads that the town never wanted or
owned in the first place that would I
now press the green button to support
adoption of this bipartisan Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker chair recognize
representative mcari for a parliamentary
inre thank you Mr
Speaker if I know the New Hampshire
Turnpike constructed ramps at exits 10
11 and 12 for the ever Turnpike improved
and extended an existing Town Road known
as Camp Sergeant creating Continental
Boulevard that relieved traffic on Route
three and enabled economic development
in those areas surrounding those ramps
for the sole benefit of marac if I know
the New Hampshire Turnpike only took on
the major investment with the express
understanding town of marac would permit
tolls to be collected for those
aforementioned ramps to pay for the
construction and the continued
maintenance and if I know that meramac
later actively pursued and secured
removal of the meramac tolls triggering
a $1.6 million annual loss of tolls and
the removal of those tolls locations
cost the turnpike $2.1
million and after all that the turnpike
is left with an expense of
$96,000 annual to maintain Continental
Boulevard as mentioned local road that
is not connected to the to the New
Hampshire Turnpike system finally if you
were not from
marac and believe as I the town of maram
should have fully considered the
financial ramification for their town
before they removed a state a revenue
stream that would have fully funded the
continue maintenance of their local Road
would you now join me and press the red
button to defeat this
amendment thank you the motion before us
is aoid floor boid floor Amendment 1269
H this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppos you press a red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
we're going to do that again
was delete
it discard save
it we don't want toore it we want to
this we're going to do this again
because that was not 30
seconds okay it was a slight malfunction
so we are going to do this again voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
repr
[Music]
represent Davis the house will be in
order representative
to over
here
while members president had an
opportunity to vote household tend to
stay to the
vote 172 voting yay 195 voting nay the
amendment
fails we're back to the majority
committee motion of autop pass as
amended on House Bill 2024 are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppos
a the eyes have it and then committee
amendment is
adopted for what reason does a member
rise a motion to print the remarks
regarding hb67 in the permanent journal
without objection
for what reason does a memory rise I
move that the remarks from uh House Bill
2024 be placed in the permanent
journal without
objection
[Music]
[Applause]
and Committee Member from marac uh at
the committee meeting after we voted
unanimously to pass the amendment you
just voted on the Department of
Environmental Services asked us uh to
reconsider and to consider a floor
Amendment they had suggested to the
committee that they did not reach out to
all the interested parties uh before
they met with us with their suggestions
so post our meeting and before today uh
my fellow representative and I work with
the Department of Environmental Services
to make this amendment there's basically
three changes in the amendment the time
period for which a seller can give you
their evaluation was reduced from 3
years to 180 days or roughly 6 months
the time which the buyer needs to
replace a fail system was reduced from
one year to 180 days or they say 6
months
I'm told that is consistent with a
normal septic failure replacement time
period so we're trying to be consistent
with the D regulations so that was
amended and the time period of which a
failed system under Section six uh needs
to be replaced that went from one year
to 180 days it was suggested to us that
again be consistent with the 180-day
period but there's also as you'll note
we remain the six-month extension in
section 7 um so those are the basic
changes they were supported uh by
partisan with the committee members and
also by the uh New Hampshire Department
of Environmental Services so would ask
for your support of this amendment thank
you motion before a har floor Amendment
132h are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I
nay guys have it in the floor amendment
is adopted motion before us now is on
pass with Amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I
iose
nay eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted majority committee on resource
Recreation development to which was
referred House Bill 1121 an act relative
to cre certain Wetlands permit
exemptions after a natural disaster or
flooding event having considered the
same report the same with the floor
Amendment following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senate Juliet Harvey
bolia for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Jessica lontine for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
112h printed in house Record 12 Pages
112 you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
committee amendment is adopted motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
no the eyes have it and the committee
amendment is
adopted
the committee on resources Recreation
and development to which was referred
House Bill 1301 relative to wake surfing
on public bodies of water comes with
recommendation representative Darby
moves ought to
pass for what reason is a member rise Mr
Speaker I move to table HB
1301 a motion there is a motion to table
1301 a division has been recall has been
called members take your seats
Derby
we've already put question
the motion the motion before
us is the
um tabling motion on House Bill
1301 this is going to be a uh division
vote and the chair recognizes
representative Ren
Zulo
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill allows
just 25 people not
necessarily Lakefront
owners to petition the department of
safety to keep certain types of people
and vessels off of their water
water and if I noted the department of
safety said that they do not have the
resources to do this at all without fund
extra funding then would I keep it clean
and hit the green thank
you J recognize representative Darby for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I knew
wake Sur can be an enjoyable sport for
young and old but large wakes in Shallow
sensitive areas of a lake can flood Lon
nests encourage toxic cyanobacteria
blooms and cause Shoreline property
damage and Mr Speaker if I knew the
amended bill was not a ban on wake
surfing and it does not add broad
restrictions but instead creates a
process for the Department of Safety to
hold hearings with existing staff to
protect these sensitive areas as it does
as it currently does for speed limit
restrictions and finally Mr Speaker if I
knew the department of safety must
balance the right to public access to
lakes with safety concerns for people
and property as well as environmental
and habitat impact would I now press the
red button to oppose the table motion so
we can move on to the debate about
protecting New Hampshire's magnificent
Lakes thank you Mr Speaker the motion
before us is the table H Bill 1301 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you will press the green button if
you're poos or press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
marter representative syes and
beay
all members presid I opportunity to vote
house attendant stay the
vote 196 voting a 172 voting a HB 1301
is laid on the
table
majority of the committee on resource
Recreation and development to which was
referred House Bill 1390 an act relative
to regulating wake boating and wake
Sports considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment present Susan Vil for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate sen Robert har
for the minority of the committee for
what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker I move to table HB
1390 is that is a tabling is an in order
motion this will be a division
vote members take your seats this will
be a division vote
excuse me
Mr
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
1390 this is
a we've already put the question
forward
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 1390 this will be a division vote
the chair recogniz representative gulo
for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill is another bill that seeks to
unfairly single out wake Sports and wake
boats for restrictions and bans on
Public public bodies of water and if I
know that the again the department of
safety doesn't have the resources in
terms of Staff or technology to carry
out this bill
then
then would I make the scene and press
the
green chair recogniz representative
Tanner for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know our Lakes are
irreplaceable natural resources and we
want to keep them clean and safe and if
I know these regulations will allow for
all boers and those recreating on our
legs to use them safely and responsibly
and if I know people will still be able
to enjoy wake surfing and if I know
these regulations will help keep our
Lakes Shoreline and wildlife habitat
safe and healthy for future Generations
would I now vote R against the tabling
motion and let the debate begin thank
you the motion before us is the table
House Bill 1390 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
mons have all members present had an
opportunity to vote how will tend to
stay to the
vote 190 voting a 178 voting a house
bill 1390 is laid on the table
ch
the majority of the committee on spe
special committee on housing which was
referred House Bill 1291 an act relative
to ACC dwelling unit uses Allowed by
right having considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
and the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment
representative alen Reed for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Thomas Walsh for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
123h printed in house Record 12 12 on
pages 136 to
137 questions on the adoption of the
amendment you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those oppos
nay the eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted now we're on to the main motion
of what now we're on to for what reason
does a member rise for a motion Mr
Speaker State your motion I'd like to
lay HB 1291 on the table and request a
division
vote
representative Phillips request a roll
call let's sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call vote members take
your
seats
e
the question is whether to aay House
Bill 1291 on the table and this is a
division vote house will be in order
members find your
seats
what
representative Walsh is recognized for
parliamentary
incorrect thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that this is a top-
down zoning change mandated by the state
if I also know that all towns are
different and one size fits-all
Solutions never work therefore why these
these therefore these things should be
decided at the local level if I know
this bill expands our current Adu
statute by forcing towns to allow a
second detached unit formally called
houses uh with a minimum of 1,000 square
fet on any single family lot over half
an acre which potentially converts
single family lots into three unit
rental properties Mr Speaker finally if
I know that simple corrections to our
current law our current Adu law without
the expansion would probably would have
come out a committee on consent wouldn't
I then press the green
button
representative Osborne's recognized for
a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the special
committee on housing was created with a
diverse group of our members to uh study
and propose solutions to the housing
issues that are of concern to our
constituents would I now press the red
button and listen to hear what they have
brought for us
today the questions whether to lay House
Bill 1291 on the
table this is a roll call vote if you
are
in
what okay if you're in favor press the
green button oppose press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
all
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the
vote 87 in the affirmative 277 in the
negative tabling fails
represented representative sodi declared
a conflict and did not participate now
now we are on the motion of ought to
pass as
amended representative spear is
recognized to speak against the
committee
report thank
you thank you Mr
Speaker this bill removes the local
control of planning boards to allocate
resources based on the needs of the
communities in which they
serve and for that reason I'm against
the
Bill Ward three which is the ward that I
represent
is part of the inner city of NASA with
the largest area of highest density
housing units in this in the community
in all of
Nashua the full inner city consists of
the South 2/3 of ward 3 Eastern portions
of w 2 four and six and the northern
portion of Ward seven the inner city
contains 30% of the 300 miles of the
Nashua sewer lines
the sewer lines in this inner city area
combine waste and
runoff in other words storm drains
they're not
separate into a single pipe all the rest
of nashwa have these
separate Manchester is currently going
through a 20year
335 million project to separate these
lines the reason this is being done is
because in
2005 the EPA filed against
Nashua and Manchester for polluting the
miramac
river we have not cleared that yet if
you've read in the news you would see
that we have dumped 20 million gallons
of w of waste water into the marac from
Nashua and
875 million gallon gallons of combined
Wastewater from Manchester that's over
three times the amount at which we were
find in the first place for polluting
the river so we've exceeded all
expectations for being able to
pollute and that's just last year and it
rained
today Nash River wasn't even included in
the 20 million
gallons
we have nine now what when H when what
happens with uh combined uh sewer pipes
is they reach something called a CSO in
other words a combined sewer overflow
Point that's the point at which it
cannot no longer siphon all of it down
into the um treatment plants and so it
just gets dumped out into the river I'm
not going to take your time explaining
that although I did read research it a
lot and it's really cool and there are
some benefits to that combination but we
far exceeded the ability to be able to
handle that anymore so the problem we
now have as a result of the 2005 finding
is that we have to fix this we've been
mandated to fix it the state of New
Hampshire has not spent any money on
this the town's taxes have to pay for it
Manchester as I indicated have to pay
335 million since it's a 25e project
it's 20-year project it's probably going
to overrun and that's the way life is
Nashua was told that in order to fix
what was left of the third as I said
that we had 300 miles of sewer there was
only 10% uh 30% of that is in an in the
area called the inner city it was going
to cost another 225 million to separate
those pipes into waste water order and
run
off nashaa said they couldn't afford it
they just didn't have the money so they
came up with another
plan the plan in Nashua to handle this
and it will get fixed over the next 10
years it hasn't been fixed yet because
we're still dumping the plan over the
next 10 years is the inner city portion
keeps the pipes together we will never
separate them out but the portion that's
in the rest of nsha they're fine and
they have and and they work well with
the very the upgraded and ex $69 million
Nash was spent uh a few years back to
upgrade the sewer facility I'm sorry
they upgrade the treatment facility and
to put a 40,000 gallon uh holding tank
to be able to hold some of that runoff
but as I said the runoff is now three
over three times what was ever expected
for it to be able to
hold the area that's in the Inner City
consists of pipes and you can read it on
the map I'm not making this up although
I was incredibly surprised to find out
myself are made out of clay they're made
out of
brick they're made out of
cement they're fragile and they're as
old as being installed In
1855 the town doesn't want to touch them
because if they do they're afraid that
the whole thing will just fall apart
although I that's my reading on it I
mean I think they don't want to do it
because it cost $250
million the streets in this area are
narrow the kind of excavation equipment
you have to get down those streets is
probably
impossible as some of Manchester is
finding out right now it's it's a
disaster but not a disaster that's going
to be forever you know you move on from
each Street at a little bit at a
time the idea of all of a sudden letting
individuals take it upon themselves to
add adus in an area that is so
fragile and is not in the process has
not completed their their uh pollution
prevention that has been mandated by the
EPA and the fact that the state of New
Hampshire is not going to help them do
one bit of this and our taxpayers have
to pay between the two cities over a
billion dollars to straighten this out
seems to me we don't need another state
mandate we got enough mandates we're
reeling from under it one of the other
problems we have in nsha and I don't
know if they have this problem in
Manchester is that our our supply of
water in this inner city area is so old
that the best we can get is 18 PSI in
this inner city area 18 PSI is not
enough to take a
shower we don't have the ability to
operate and just let individuals do this
sort of thing now that this bill would
let you believe that the town has done
nothing for housing uh nasua has put in
over 2,000 housing units in the last two
years alone but they've been able to
rate the p uh rate uh route the pipes to
an area that has split runoff and split
sewer not in the middle of for area the
uh that we're talking
for that's okay you probably couldn't
hear me cuz I can't really hear you
which is shocking considering only about
half the members are in here we please
keep it quiet and minimize holding the
doors in the back open sorry go
ahead as I said we don't need another
mandate telling us that we have to take
on individuals not being allow being
allowed to do what they want with their
with their properties as far as
impacting the the the sewer system that
we all share and that we depend on in
this inner city area other areas of nsha
maybe something can be done maybe it's
okay but we need to plan because this
area is so fragile that we don't have
much that we don't have until they fix
the rest of the uh dumping
problem we're just going to keep getting
fined by the
EPA and as I say the state isn't helping
with that also I said mentioned that the
water system we have every time new
houses are put on this water system our
pressure goes
down we just don't have the facility in
this area other areas do and so other
areas could be planned for more housing
and could be planned but as I say nashar
has put in over 2,000 new housing units
and they've done it by routing the water
and the and the uh sewer from another
area not from inside of our inner city
area this is all part of planning this
is what this is the way what planners do
we can't take that away from them and so
I'm asking you to itl this
uh this bill and I would ask for a
division
vote representative turkos recognize
speak against the
report
thank you Mr Speaker I want to start out
by saying one thing dispelling a
misconception out there that this is
something about this bill is something
about property
rights the only people's property rights
are who are going to be negatively
affected are those who are going to be
affected by the mandates that the state
is handing down this is zoning by the
state this is not property
rights if you want to talk about giving
property rights back to the people I've
got a great solution let's put forth
a a bill that actually just eliminates
all zoning take care of it you get your
property rights back I don't think there
have been too many people are going to
be going along with
that the current rsas allow the
municipality to make zoning changes with
the war and article process that is
local
control
that is what the municipal and County
government committee consistently
applies when we talk about zoning and
the nhma strongly
endorses that concept of local
control so what does this bill attempt
to force on
municipalities allows two adus now it
used to be one now you're going to have
two one attached one unattached it
increases the size of the first one hey
you got a
garage make it an an
Adu have a space above a
garage convert that to a second
Adu have some ex have a big shed in the
backyard hey do a little work on that
and convert that to an
Adu now according to the some of the
language in there also it says the
second Adu shall be required to meet the
definition of Workforce
housing and shall be required to meet
the definition of affordable as defined
in the
rsas we just killed a bill here a couple
weeks ago regarding rent
control on the smaller
lots a primary residence your 2 adus
could P potentially take up nearly every
square foot of that
property so where are the cars going to
park
well this language takes care of that
and this is what it says at a legally
dedicated offsite location at the
property owner's discretion so where is
that going to be is it going to be a
block away two blocks away half a mile
away a mile away or is it more likely
going to be the result that the renters
of the adus Start parking on and
clogging up the seats uh streets near
the
units you're going to have negative
aesthetic and social effects on the
neighborhoods there's no way to get
around it let's say you bought in a
neighborhood consisting of Sam family
homes like my mom grew up in in the
North End of
Manchester when you buy a piece of
property you have an expectation of the
zoning when you buy and you expect that
zoning to remain and not be negated by
the
state and with this you're going to have
no input on it when the state mandates
it
down it's not the warrant article
process so not going to have a vote in
that
process the previous speaker mentioned
the demands on the Municipal Water and
Sewer
infrastructure who's going to pay for
that what about will the rapid increase
in the newcomers require increased
police EMT presence increased trash
collection what is the increased cost to
the taxpayers how many new school age
kids will be enrolling who are living in
the adus who have one or two one or two
or more children living on the property
does an extra ,000 collected in taxes
cover the additional $20,000 per
student no it doesn't so again I'll ask
what will be the cost to the
taxpayers now I'm going to go off a
little bit here and talk about
process I want to talk about the special
committee on
housing that's a 10-minute member
committee
committee this bill before you right
here nine of the 10 committee
members were sponsors of this
bill this committee heard this
Bill had the
hearing exect it and then sent it to the
floor on a vote of 9 to one does anybody
see anything a little off with that I
sure do am will suspend yes
motives are off limits the what motives
are off
limits
okay these bills belong in Municipal and
County government where the subject
matter experts
reside and I can tell you remember will
suspend the speaker assigns the bills he
put them where they were
appropriate
correct all right we'll move on to the
wrapup how's
that so again let's
talk that these Adu structures would be
a mandate and take away the local
control don't be misled by the language
the Sounder softing language that these
bills a lot of these bills contain
Allowed by a matter of right no to be
clear this means your M municipalities
must allow the two adus in this case
it's not an
option politicians in conquer do not
understand and know the needs and wants
of distant municipalities such as
Pittsburgh or Hampton or Lebanon or NASA
or my town of barington to believe we
know better is simply wrong don't
infringe on the municipality's
role of
zoning
and I'm going to end with an
axom that we used to say at the Allied
Pilots Association where the member of
Kingston used to also be a member while
I was in leadership there as a member of
a
15,000 uh pilot
Union during my leadership roles
whenever we were in contract negotiation
times we used to have a
saying and the saying was a good
contract sells itself
no sales job to the members is
required that axium applies to
legislation Al also I'll ask that you
support the uh that you oppose the
emotion uh the motion of ought to pass
so another motion can be made thank you
Mr
Speaker representative Alexander's
recognized speak and support of the
committee
report thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
want to to spell a bunch of the
narratives that's being pushed off today
um I but first I want to thank you for
forming not you in particular but the
speaker um behind you for forming the
special committee on housing because out
of these bills there's only two on the
regular calendar five are on consent we
got some really good stuff done
regarding small targeted changes at the
approval processes and unnecessary codes
this bill came into place because of a
law that was signed allowing Adu by
right in SB 14 6 in 2016 since then
municipalities have gone around this law
by putting in arbitrary parking mandates
setback requirements in order to
restrict Property Owners from building
adus on their own land now I believe
unless there is a health or safety issue
you should not have a right to tell
someone what they can and cannot do with
their own
property this bill is a clarifying bill
that makes it clear that municipalities
cannot restrict an Adu by right by
changing the definition of attached
versus detached and allowing one Adu to
be detached but the second one has to be
attached it also makes it clear that a
municipality cannot say You must have
five or six parking spaces that seems a
little ridiculous for an Adu that's th
Square ft you need six parking spaces
this is how municipalities zone out this
types of building and it's wrong in my
opinion but under HP 1291 local
governments still have the ability to do
all these things ready I'm going to
listen list them off if they have the
right to restrict it if it lacks
sufficient space because the setback
requirements a private well a wet land
or the property line are not adequate if
it lacks sufficient land to construct an
adequate SEPTA system they can deny it
based on science based on health based
on safety if it lacks drinkable water
you can deny it if it lacks adequate
parking if it lacks adequate fire
protection min alties may also require
that the owner occupies one of the units
that means that they're I don't know
like people know the people that are
living in that
property this bill is the gentlest way
possible to increase the housing supply
for this state New Hampshire voters have
indicated that housing availability is
the number one issue affecting them we
have generations of granite Staters
looking for their retirement home first
home and dream home and lack the lack of
supply has led to stagnation in the
market no one is moving let's give
Property Owners the right to build on
their own property join me vote green
thank
you the questions on the motion of V
passed as amended on House Bill
1291 representative Grangers requested a
roll call is sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
the
CU I'm
IR
e
the questions on the motion about to
pass on House Bill
representative wal is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I still know this is a top down
one-size fits-all state mandate if I
also know that these decisions are best
done in our local towns they have the
knowledge of the towns and finally Mr
Speaker if I know that my voting no on
this aop pass I'll be able to go back to
my town and look at the citizens in the
and say I voted for your decision then
wouldn't I press the green
button
red that's why we
ask representative Bui is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that we are in the midst of a
severe housing shortage and a record
high rental market with thousands of new
units needed and Mr Speaker if I know
that house build
1291 is a step in the right direction to
allow Property Owners to build
additional units adus to allow young
adults and an aging population on a
fixed income who cannot afford the high
rent along with disabled people who
cannot find or afford safe housing and
now Mr speaker we know that
um uh these units can um
also cause uh potential home buyers to
qualify for a mortgage and finally Mr
Speaker House Bill 1291 has a blessing
of many people across the state and
groups who came to our committee such as
New Hampshire Housing Finance the
Realtors and a disabled Community to
name a few now Mr Speaker should I now
press the green button and take a giant
step towards to face this housing crisis
headon thank
you the questions on the motion of to
pass as amended on House Bill 1291
there's a roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
wheeler
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house attend of the
state of the
vote 220 in the affirmative 14 three and
the negative and with representative
sodi declaring a conflict and not
participating the motion's
adopted the majority of the special
committee on housing to which was
referred House Bill 1399 an act allowing
municipalities to permit two residential
units and certain single family
residential zones having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative joshell for the majority
of the committee the minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Thomas Walsh
with the minority of the committee the
amendment is 1157 H printed an house
Record 12 on pages 148 to 149 the
questions on the adoption of the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay the eyes haven't the
Amendments adopted now we're on the main
motion of ought to pass as amended
representative Len turkot recognized to
speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker again I rise
in opposition to House Bill
1399 this bill requires that on all lots
of two acres or less and at least 50% of
single family Zone Lots duplexes shall
be allowed Again by right based on the
section of the proposed RSA a two-unit
residence would be permitted on property
zoned industrial commercial agricultural
historic district any property of 2
Acres or less and the municipality must
accept it it cannot be
denied this bill has an interesting
Clause exception that deals with water
and
sewer we know that adding up to the
additional
50% up to an additional 50% of
residential units in a city will
definitely increase the demands on the
water and sewer line this bill states
you have 10 years to upgrade your water
system and if you don't well we can
build it Anyway by right I think we all
agree that the state compelling zoning
changes and forcing a city to redo their
water and seore without providing
funding is therefore an unfunded
mandate the municipali planners are
going to have to develop some ex
extraordinary powers of ESP on this one
as it would require the municipality to
be able to predict all future proposed
development once it does that then it
has to determine what proposed
development meets to Al uh to alteration
or demolition criteria and then attempt
to predict and allocate between the two
acres or less slots and 50% of
residential lots confused
yet I've gone over this thing multiple
multiple times and I still am confused
by this one just imagine being one of
the planning uh or the individuals in
your town who has to figure this one out
and implement it once the municipality
calculates how many of the two acres or
less qualified then it must divide out
those zone for single family homes and
then determine whether that is 50% of
the state should not be forcing mandates
onto towns and cities takeing away the
property rights of the municipalities
current
residents is there even a remote
possibility that the
M scenario where the municipality is
going to be able to figure out even how
to comply with this legislation the
legislation has been poorly drafted and
it is
inadequate uh has inadequately been
analyzed for its practical application
I'll say once again that local control
of zoning is a long-standing practice
that gives the municipalities and its
citizens the ability to change zoning if
they
determine by Warren article top- down
zoning changes by the state couched as
getting back property rights is
misleading you do not force many people
to accept the will of a few politicians
or bureaucrats that is Central planning
at its worst I ask you to oppose the
motion of otpa so another o u motion can
be made thank you Mr Speaker does a
member yield for a
question why
not representative com May inquire thank
you Mr Speaker and thank you for taking
my question um I live in a town where we
have a 2 acre minimum lot size um and we
also have controlled growth how will
this affect us I missed the last part
said um we also have controlled growth
by enabling homeowners to expand
existing single family homes into
duplexes or build new duplex homes on
smaller Lots in single family
residential zones this increases housing
options and provides more units to
address New Hampshire's housing shortage
crisis this bill allows duplexes to be
built in 50% of single family
residential zones and lots of two acres
or less in size by right provided that
new duplex does meet certain criteria
duplexes are light density and from the
street they are often the same size and
appearance as a single family house you
can't even tell it's a
duplex we can no longer wait for local
control to fix the problem of overly
restrictive local zoning
ordinances down zoning when a parcel of
land is rezoned from a prior more
intense use to more restricted use is
what we're dealing with right here right
now local control will not fix the
problem of historical down zoning which
is why this bill is needed to restore
duplexes are missing middle housing
duplexes do not devalue property and
impacted zones duplexes do not force
municipalities to increase sewer and
water capacity in fact we have two
special Clauses in the bill to address
concerns about sewer and water issues
and finally there's the concern that if
there's a public health and safety issue
you may ask the state for a finding to
find your way around not allowing
duplexes so there is an out finally in
terms of impact on local local planning
boards local planning boards can still
impose objective zoning limitations even
with this bill height limitations
building setbacks allowable lot coverage
and of course our historic and other
overlay districts still apply so in
conclusion I ask you to please support
this bill so that we can bring back
missing middle housing that we had 50
years ago until it was down zoned by our
local ordinances thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report about to pass as
amended representative grer requests
roll calls that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
it'll be a roll call
vote members take your
seats
e
questions on the majority committee
report about to pass as amended on House
Bill 1399 this is a roll call vote
representative Walsh is recognized for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr
Speaker if I know this is another top-
down zoning change mandated by the state
uh and and if I know I this one's a
little different because I really don't
have a problem with
duplexes uh but Mr Speaker if I know the
problem is with how the bill is written
uh demolition requirements and
percentages percentages of lots and
residential lots versus residential lots
the need to estimate future growth to
maintain the 50% that's required with
the very real chance of spot zoning
which as you heard is
illegal uh if I also know Mr Speaker
that I don't want you to take my word
for it uh but an attorney from the
Hampshire Municipal Association sent out
uh a communication stating quote due to
the complexity of mathematics here I
simply do not see any scenario where any
municipality in the state would be able
to comply with this legislation
unquote Mr Speaker finally if I know
this is a mandate that doesn't work and
we should do better to pass laws would I
then press the red
button representative Damon recogniz for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that duplexes are
coste effective missing middle housing
but they've been difficult to build due
to local zoning restrictions and if I
know this bill includes solid
protections for municipalities to apply
objective standards as well as
permitting an exemption if there is
specific adverse effect upon public
health and safety and if if I know
increasing our housing availability is
critical to maintaining a sufficient
Workforce in New Hampshire and that this
bill passed our bike partisan committee
by a 9 to1 vote would I now press the
green button to facilitate creating
desperately needed housing thank
you questions on the majority committee
report of ought to pass as amended House
Bill 1399 it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
wner
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house attend of the
state of the
vote 220 in the affirmative 140 and the
negative the motion's adopted
representative sod declared a conflict
and did not
participate the committee on state
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
to which is referred house resolution 31
an act urging support of the dignity
through Prosperity act having instead of
the same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative Michael
Moffett for the committee for what
reason does the member rise I'd like to
make a motion please State your motion
I'd like to table this bill
please the motion is to
table house res resolution 31 you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those oppose
nay the eyes have it and it's laid on
the
table
speak M Mr Speaker for what reason does
the member rise thank you Mr Speaker to
make a motion State your motion I'd like
to um uh remove House Bill 546 from the
table representative luno moves to P
House Bill 546 off the
table well the motion is going to be to
remove House Bill 546 from the table and
a division vote representative Sweeney
request a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote so members
take your
seats
just
the question is whether to remove House
Bill 546 from the table representative
luno is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much M Mr Speaker
if I know that house bill 546 has passed
this chamber before and that it offers a
responsible increase increas to school
building Aid and provide some relief to
projects and taxpayers that have been
hung up for more than a decade uh during
the moratorium then would I press the
green button to support this motion
thank you very
much representative sween's recognized
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
sky is almost dark and Mr Speaker if I
know that we tabled this bill back in
January we've had a number of great
bipartisan wins today we can roll
through the rest of the calendar uh
would I now press the red button to keep
this on the table where it's been since
January thank
you the question is whether to remove
House Bill 546 from the table is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button oppos press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend the state of the vote
182 in the affirmative 179 in a negative
546 is removed from the
[Music]
table
representative Kate Murray moves a to
pass on House Bill 546 and requests a
division vote members take your
seats represent Sweeney request a roll
call is that sufficiently Yep this will
be a roll call vote members take your
seats for what reasons do member R
question of the chair
Yep this bill has a a
uh fiscal note attached to it have we
passed the deadline for dealing with
both bills going to a second committee
the
committee uh the bill was in finance so
that's not a
problem thank
you
the motion is ought to pass on House
Bill
546 representative Murray is recognized
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that we are woefully behind in
our responsibility to provide Clean safe
and modern schools for our children in
New Hampshire and if I know before us we
have have an excellent opportunity to
provide additional support for school
building Aid beyond what was provided in
the budget and that this is both a
phisically responsible move as well as a
governmentally and civically responsible
move if I know that even if we are still
behind in building Aid this additional
funding will provide great help to
several more schools and will put us on
a better path towards addressing the
school building issues that we face and
lastly if I know that this will not only
benefit our students but will also have
a positive impact on our future
Workforce when I now press the green
button to support the out to pass motion
thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the motion of V
to pass and House Bill 546 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote the house will attend to the
state of the vote 182 in the affirmative
178 in the negative the motion is
adopted the committee on transportation
to which was referred House Bill 1273 FN
an act relative to the protection of
personal information in driver's
licenses having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study representative Ted Gorski for the
committee the questions on the motion of
inum study are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is
adopted house now ATT 10 to bills
removed from the consent calendar for
what reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker having voted um on the
prevailing side on House Bill 546 I move
reconsideration and urge the membership
to vote
no represent Weber moves reconsideration
on House Bill
546 and request a division vote members
take your
seats
the motion is reconsideration on House
Bill 54 6 members should be in their
seats if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote th attend to the
state of the
vote 172 in the affirmative 188 in the
negative reconsideration
fails
e
we read the whole
thing the committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety to which is referred
House Bill
1711 FN act authorizing the state to
report Mental Health Data for firearms
background check purposes providing for
processes for confiscation of firearms
following a certain mental health
related Court proceeding and for relief
from mental health related Firearms
disabilities we considered the same
report same with the following Amendment
the recommendation of Bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen David us for the
committee for what reason does a member
rise to make a higher priority Motion
state your motion I move to table House
Bill
1711 that is a proper motion the motion
before add is the table House
Bill
1711 a division has been requested this
will be a division vote members take
your
seats
the motion before us is to the table
houseal bill 1711 this is a division
vote chair recognizes representative ho
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I'm aware that there are at
least two floor amendments on this bill
if I'm aware that it's after six o'clock
and we're going to be here for a while
and Mr Speaker if I know that there are
some unintended consequences with the
bill as currently drafted that is
addressed by one of the floor amendments
would I now vote Yes to table this Bill
thank
you chair recognize representative Roy
for parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that Chief
Bradley H probably wishes he was here at
6 o'clock tonight would I not table this
bill the motion before us is to table
House Bill
1711 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppos you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
e
[Music]
all members president had the
opportunity to vote household tend to
state of the
vote 150 voting aay 205 voting nay
motion
fails
okay
the committee amendment is
0431 H printed in house Record 12 Pages
169 are you ready for the question on
the committee Amendment all those in
favor say I
iOS
n guys have it the committee amendment
is
adopted bill on Bill bills on second
reading open to further
Amendment representative kto office
floor Amendment
135h it's in your seat
Pockets J recognizes representative
W thank you Mr Speaker the amendment
that's in your seat pocket relative to
this
Bill takes the bill that we have and
turns it into a study committee it does
that for multiple
reasons the amendment that was just
adopted by this
body includes involuntary admissions
what does that mean let's say you have a
child
who came down with a serious issue a
medical issue of some sort I'm going to
use anorexia because that's clearly a a
potential for self harm right or harm
harm to the person in a significant
way you could have a Court rule that
that person needs to go to the hospital
and stay there until they're in a better
position is that person a criminal is
that person dangerous to themselves well
they have an eating disorder but I'm not
sure they're dangerous to
themselves when we draft legislation we
should be really
clear about the terms
this uses the same broad language that's
in current federal
statutes and that broad language doesn't
necessarily apply to all the cases in
New
Hampshire people that struggle with
mental health issues shouldn't be
treated as criminals should not be put
on a criminal database people that have
mental health issues should in fact get
the care that they
need by forcing this bill through even
with the committee Amendment what we're
saying is if you have a mental health
issue you're a
criminal on the other side and I
disbelieve that completely on the other
side we're saying that if you take away
their firearms even when a courtroom has
or court has deemed that they're
dangerous they're suddenly magically
safe do we really believe
that I remember a number of years ago
where Timothy McVey used diesel Fuel and
fertilizer to end the lives of over 150
people I would call
him um a danger to others whether he had
a prior mental health record is is not
the point I'm arguing the point I'm
arguing right now is he was clearly a
threat to others and needed
help and unfortunately he he demolished
the
building we have a chance to study this
issue right now to address the issues
and the concerns raised by everybody
from the disability rights
groups all the way over to the gun
groups this is the time to do that I
would ask that you would adopt the floor
Amendment
133h so that we can go on and finish out
our evening thank
you J recogize representative
Roy Mr
Speaker
don't fall for straw man arguments this
has nothing to do with eating disorders
or manure bombs this has got to do with
whether or not someone is dangerous to
themselves or others and has had two
hearings in court has had a lawyer
assigned to them and even after that oh
and excuse me has also been committed
prior to that for 10 days for
observation even after all that the
court has said you are likely a danger
to yourselves or others
if someone can find me someone who's had
their weapons taken for anorexia I will
give you my next year's salary from
here I don't anticipate I'll be doing
that so let's be serious this is a
serious issue we don't need to study it
we've been fighting back and forth about
this now for over 10 years and in that
time while we keep doing these little
these little Maneuvers three police
officers have been shot by people who
should have been committed and who were
committed and should have been on that
list and one of them's dead so I ask you
to not support this uh amendment to
study let's get on with it get to the
final vote and be
done the motion before us is the conto
floor Amendment
135 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I
I those opposed say
Nay n the eyes have it the n have the NS
have it the Nays have
it I wasn't expecting a Voice vote uh
the NS have it the floor Amendment
fails bills on second reading open to
further Amendment representative H
offers floor Amendment
H thank you Mr Speaker this is the more
complex Amendment and and although it's
two pages front and or whatever one page
front and back it is exactly what was
adopted in the amendment from the
committee with two small
changes the first changes in the first
couple of paragraphs relative to whether
you're a harm to others or just a harm
to yourself sorry a harm to yourself or
harm to yourself and
others this carves out those that are
potentially a harm to themselves and
says those names shouldn't be going into
Nicks this was the issue I brought up
earlier those people right are in
different category than those that were
ruled or adjudicated as not Reason Not
competent to stand
trial or were ruled Not Guilty by reason
of insanity or were or were a court has
ruled where there are danger to
others the other part of this
amendment is on the is on the back
relative to what to do about the fact
that officer
hos was standing guard at a metal
detector he was the perimeter of
security for the state
hospital he was a former police
chief and all the police officers I know
carry personally on their own time so
why was the person Manning the security
booth Manning the metal
detector not carrying a personal firearm
that day when he probably would have
been for his personal protection outside
of his job that
day that family deserves to know the
answers to that question and it's time
to form the study committee to figure
out why he was disarmed when he was
acting as the
security officer hos was still alive
when he got to the hospital that day and
while the psychiatric hospital is kind
of diagonally across the street from
conquered Hospital they're relatively
close it's it's
not it's not just a 30- second jaunt
between the two it takes a little bit of
time to get between those two buildings
I would argue that his family deserves
to know the answers so this amendment
carves out the simply carves out those
who might be a danger to
themselves and creates a study committee
Mr Speaker I would ask for a roll call
vote on the adoption of this
amendment chair recognize representative
Roy
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I would
ask everyone take a look at that
Amendment take a look at the end of that
Amendment it says we want to know we
want a study committee to study whether
the state of New Hampshire is complicit
in the murder of Chief H think about
that that's what the amendment he's
asking you to vote on to study was it
was the state of New Hampshire complicit
in the murder of that man because he was
alive when he went to work that day so
therefore he was stripped of his firearm
so rather than say someone who's been
committed to a mental institution
because they are danger to herself or
others we should make it easier for
other people to shoot them that that's
what he's
saying again don't fall for it let's get
to the main issue vote no to this
amendment representative H has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
St
the motion before us is ought to
pass is amendment the whole floor
Amendment
8h this is a roll call
vote chair recognized represent H for a
parliamentary inquiry wave
off representative Roy waves
off the motion before us is the whole
floor
Amendment
1358 H this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppos you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
run
all members present have the opportunity
to vote househ will tend to stay to the
vote 101 voting a 252 voting a floor
Amendment
field now we're on to ought to pass as
amended
chair recognize representative
H thank you Mr Speaker I'll make this
short third time at the well is more
than
enough the bill before you has issues we
have a choice in this do we pass
legislation right now that needs
work and hope the other body behind us
fixes
it or do we take the time and delay the
passage of this so that at some point in
the future a better version of this bill
could be brought forward I would ask
that you would vote no on the autopass
as adopted or amended motion thank
you chair recognize representative
Prout thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I wish to focus on
the confiscation act of this aspect of
this bill this aspect goes beyond any
requirement of federal
law these procedures do not address
situations that are well known to be
quite common place joint ownership of
firearms this can either be by husband
and wife or with more extended family
via
trust this is extremely common place
especially with higher value and
collectible Firearms as an estate
planning tool and for other reasons how
common place you may Wonder there's
lawyers that specialize in creating
these firearm trusts and purpose-made
tools for creating these trusts from
templates in fact I'm fairly certain
there's a kiosk on the counter of a gun
store might have town to create and
print a trust just before your
completing your purchase of the next
next counter
over Firearms do not have Deeds or
registered titles like houses or
cars however this law cannot function
without that and will lead to firearm
registration there are firearms within
my family that have been passed down
from Generations that have died and it
is totally unclear who owns them they
weren't line ated in the will and all
the descendants can use them if they
want to and it's never really been
discussed who owns
them this bill directs the judge to
inquire if the person has access to any
Firearms it gives no guidance about what
the judge should do with that
information should the court or order
the owner the of them to remove access
or just confiscate them
too this lack of clarity will cause
problems this bill uh gives discretion
to unelected judges to approve transfers
of firearms to non-prohibited
individuals but without any guidance on
the factors to be considered when
exercising this
discretion this sets up individuals for
wildly different treatment depending on
which judge they
get faced with all these uncertainties
it is abundantly clear that what will
happen in the practice is the police
decease any and all firearms
tangentially related to the individual
and let the courts figure it
out if passed this bill will infringe on
the rights of anyone cohabitating with a
prohibited
person I have had close family members
that have experienced Mental Health
crisis I am a gun owner and they were as
well it was something we had to deal
with as part of the
situation another aspect of that
situation was at one point they couldn't
live alone and so as a family we made a
plan that plan did involve
cohabitating if this bill were a law at
that time the option would have been off
the table this bill would have been
directed to the come from my guns
too it would have been put the burden on
me to prove ownership of each item a
burden I'm not confident I could have
met and it's unclear that even if I had
if I would have been allowed to keep
them in the same
household I would have been forced to
make a
choice that's a terrible thing to do to
a family in crisis it'll make the me
make mental health issues in our society
worse not better it'll erode the support
structures that these people have it
will make them even more of a pariah and
close doors to them it will infringe on
the rights of far more people than just
those that have been formerly
adjudicated as outlined in this bill I
urge you to press the red button and
vote against this Bill thank you Mr
Speaker J recognize representative
beler
thank you Mr Speaker hello colleagues I
won't take long with this uh there are
portions of this bill that seem entirely
reasonable to me unfortunately there are
some parts that I have a little bit more
concern about there's a long history if
we look back on all of the nations in
the 20th century of this of this planet
where authoritarian or totalitarian
regimes made a habit of calling their
opposition and dissidence insane and
using that premise to remove their
rights this happened across every
country of the Soviet block this
happened in Cuba this happened in China
it's happened in a lot of
places now why would I bring that up
it's not like there's any risk of
something like that ever happening here
right there's no totalitarian or
authoritarian or suppressive movements
happening in the United States of
America right let me read you just one
one statement one line from the mission
statement of the American Psychological
Association the APA is committed to the
infusing the principles of equity
diversity and inclusion into all aspects
of the work we
do thank you please vote
R CH recognize representative
Roy thank you Mr Speaker M okay so a
couple things um first first of all you
may wonder where did where did I get
this uh this language from because you
know we hear this part's a little
problematic that part's a little
problematic I got this language from the
NRA that's where I got this language
from I got this language from the NRA I
got this language from 48 other states
that have this bill I haven't heard of
anybody um in all these states that have
had this for years anyone who's been
lost their guns because of anorexia I
haven't heard of any any other issues
with regard to the representative's
question about confiscation of guns um I
worked very closely with nami on this
issue I made sure that people had a
choice their guns are not going to be
confiscated and brought to some police
locker and thrown in a closet they the
people have a choice of where they can
go they can transfer them to a friend
relative an FFL we went out of our way
to make sure that our bill while
complying with the federal statutes has
more freedom than any other states the
person could choose where they fire arms
go who gets them so we we worked very
carefully also the language I worked
with nami I worked with the attorney
general and I worked with the courts all
of them looked at this language very
specifically it went through 12 13 maybe
more edits before it was just right and
more importantly what I haven't heard
anyone say is there's a restoration of
Rights process in this bill right now
New Hampshire does not have one you
cannot ever in your life get your
Firearms back if they are listed for a a
mental health thing right now there's
over a thousand people on that list from
New Hampshire and more can be added all
the time because this isn't the only way
you can get on there so if you are
listed for example if you go to your
doctor and you tell your doctor I'm
thinking about killing myself and the
doctor believes you they have to report
that to the Department of Safety who can
report that to Nyx right now without
this so there's names on list right now
from New Hampshire for people that
cannot buy firearms because of mental
health disabilities and they are banned
for the rest of their life because the
federal government will not remove
anyone's name from that list unless your
state has an approved restoration of
rights program in law I put that in this
bill and what's more not one name from
New Hampshire is allowed to go on that
list until the restoration of rights
program is approved by the ATF that
means if no one's name can go on get off
no one's name goes on so we put so many
Protections in this there's only so much
we can
do I made sure that we are protecting
people and I'm protecting Second
Amendment gun owners at the same time
the way such States as Florida and Texas
and Alaska have also done and if you
think that they're not proun States I
suggest you need to do a little research
please support this let's get this out
and make sure that another tragedy
doesn't Happ happen and we don't end up
with the real red flag bill because we
just discussed about what's going to
happen when bills get over there well
what happens when there's different
people over there and in the corner
office think about that this is our
chance to put our Line in the Sand that
we agree something has to be done but
not take everyone's guns thank
you the mo the motion before us is aut
to pass on House Bill
1711 there has been a request for a
division members pres H request a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
C
the mo the motion before is a to pass as
amended House Bill 1711 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote how will attendance state to the
vote 20 4 voting a 149 voting a
committee report is
adopted committee on transportation to
which was referred House
Bill 1637 an act relative to reducing
requirements for vehicle inspections
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation of Bill ought to pass
with Amendment presume John sers for the
committee committee amendment is 1222 H
printed in house Record 12 Pages 166
through
168 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay no the eyes have it the
committee amendment is
adopted bills bills on second reading
open to further Amendment
representative representa representative
Sykes office floor
Amendment
135h and is recognized to speak to his
Amendment thank you colleagues this is
just a the the floor men before you just
adopts all the language we just approved
as amended and is just fixing a drafting
error and by adding the following
language show evidence of part three
section B show evidence of pitting on
50% or more of the friction surface this
was a language that uh the the r the
ranking member myself the chair of the
committee and and others were uh in
agreement with so I would appreciate
your
support the motion before us is the syes
floor Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the motion now before us is
ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for
the a division has been requested this
will be a division vote members take
your
seats
for
the motion before for is ought to pass
as amended on House Bill
1637 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your opposer press a the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
repres
representes
all members president had the
opportunity to vote house will attend to
State the
vote all members present have an
opportunity to votee the
vote the motion passes 349
to6
for what reason does a member rise for a
motion State your motion I would like to
remove House Bill 1390 from the
table
sorry
guys
you
the motion before us is to remove House
Bill 1390 from the table chair
recognizes representative wolf to speak
to his
motion thank
you right if I know that I didn't have
the opportunity to present the bill as I
wanted and if I know that what is
written in the calendar is totally
different than the floor am would make
it
so so I am asking so if I know that by
bringing this motion to the floor I'm
asking the opportunity to reconsider a
tabling there is and look at the floor
Amendment thank you very much I know I
don't have a lot of time
soat represent members to be in your
seat members need to be in your seats
we're in the voting mode chair recognize
representative
Sweeney thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that a strong bipartisan
majority of this legislative body placed
this bill on the table just mere hours
ago and Mr Speaker if I further know the
underlying bill would destroy the
culture present on countless New
Hampshire Lakes would I now press the
red button and keep this awful bill on
the table where it belongs thank you
the house will be in
order the motion before us to remove
House Bill 1390 from the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
here
representative
B represent
tur wmer V preson had an opportunity to
vote house will tend to stay to the
vote
165 voting a 188 voting a the motion
fails representative duette is
recognized for a
motion State your motion uh thank you
sir after voting on the prevailing side
i' like to reconsider House Bill
12 excuse me 1283 sorry 1283 1283
sorry how will be in
order
chair recognizes representative
Stapleton
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I Rise to support the
reconsider of HP
1283 in Judiciary Committee we worked a
long time on this bill both pro and con
and we received
volumes of testimony at the hearings as
well as VIA mail email and
telephone we also o had a
vote that was differential only by three
votes back on the
21st and late in the
day the bill
before 1283 had about 373 members
present by the time this 1283 was voted
on about
430 we ended up with
355 so we had 17 or so members not
present maybe because of the one minute
rule maybe because of people taking a
break who knows but this bill must be
considered and it's important enough to
consider reconsider this bill so that we
have all members present or all members
have the
opportunity to vote on this especially
those were out of the hall on the
21st
this is this bill is so important that
it can change life and law in the state
of New Hampshire going
forward so I ask you to vote green for
the reconsider so we can give those
members a chance to have a say and a
vote that we're out of the chamber on
the 21st thank you do the member yield
the
questions yes member
yields thank you Mr Speaker thank you
representative uh do you realize that
Adolf Hitler started his his reign of
terror with youth in
Asia uh yes I do realize that's a part
of history recorded thank you chair
recognize representative
ulla thank you Mr Speaker today I Rise
uh to express my Firm Stance against
this reconsideration of the Medical Aid
and dying
legislation we have dedicated over an
hour to thoughtful and impassion
speeches elucidating the significance of
this issue and the profound impact that
H it has on the lives of our citizens to
attain another hour of debate would only
be redundant but also disrespectful to
the weightly deliberations that have
already taken place while I'm committed
to fostering and understanding uh
understanding and continuing education
on this matter I am apprehensive that
the additional discourse will sway those
members who priori State control over
individual autonomy the right to make
decisions regarding one's own life and
end of Life Care should be subject not
subject to governmental interference and
it is imperative that we uphold the
principles of personal freedom and
dignity in matters as deeply personal as
this therefore I urge my esteemed
colleagues to stand firm in their convi
convictions and resist the call for
reconsideration let us honor the
deliberative process that has brought us
to this point and focus our efforts on
advancing policies that uphold the
fundamental rights and values of our
constituents thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative
Pentel
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
matter is a sorry is of grave
concern and that we owe it to our
constituents
to debate this one more time before we
make a final decision would I press the
green button in support of
reconsideration J I recognize
representative
Sheriff
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker two
weeks ago you had
laryngitis and you to asked if I would
give the deputy speaker a well-deserved
break and I was very happy to do it and
to be back at the podium again brought
back a lot of wonderful memories for me
a few days after that I had a a friend
from the Republican caucus asked me a
question he said Steve you up at the
podium as speaker what would you do if
there was a tie vote would you vote with
us the majority
Republicans or would you feel obliged to
vote with your Democratic
colleagues and I said you know that's
really a wonderful question but for me
it's an easy question to
ask um you know for eight years I was
Democratic leader and I always told our
caucus at the end of our caucuses ad
nauseum that remember you always vote
your conscience you always vote your
district and if you can you vote your
party and so if we had a tie vote I
wouldn't necessarily vote with Democrats
or Republicans I'd vote what my
conscience told me to
do when we took up this bill on the
house floor I struggled like a lot of
you here on how to vote for moral
grounds religious reasons and so many
others and when I walked into this
chamber I still wasn't sure how I was
going to vote we had an hours long
debate and we had excellent speeches on
both sides of the aisle and on both
sides of the
issue one speak speech in particular
resonated with me and when the vote came
I pushed the red V button I voted no on
this as I said we had an hourlong debate
we had excellent commentary from people
on both sides of this
question but now is the time in the
Democrat process that this bill move on
to the Senate so they can do what they
can
do Mr Speaker my conscience is telling
me now to vote no and I hope your
conscience is telling you the same thing
thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
reconsideration
vote on
1283 a division has been requested by
representative Sweeny members take their
seats
e
the motion before us is
reconsider house will be in
order
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill 1283 this is a division
vote chair recognized representative
Mooney for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker and good
evening members of the house if I know
that over 40 state representatives
missed the vote on House Bill
1283 and if I know that there are
members who voted and now expressed
interest in rev voting and lastly if I
know that we and our constituents
deserve an accurate count of where we
stand as a body on this sensitive and
important vote despite the lateness of
the hour then would I press the green
button on the motion to reconsider thank
you chair recognize representative eaten
for a parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know just last
week we had a lengthy spirited
informative and very respectful debate
on a very sensitive issue Mr Speaker if
I know that
1283 provides numerous guard rails for
all persons
involved including the
families Mr Speaker if I not the final
vote was based on empathy dignity
compassion and a respect for personal
individual liberty and finally Mr
Speaker if I know Recons if
reconsideration does occur there are 11
speakers signed up would I now vote no
to the pending
motion the motion before us is
reconsideration on House Bill
1283 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you press the green
button if you're oppos you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote househ will attend to state to
the
vote 147 voting a yay 110 voting nay
reconsider motion fails the chair
recognize the member from arburn
represent Osborne for the third reading
motion thank you resolve that the house
now adjourned from the early session
that the business of the late session be
in order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only and
resolutions by caption only that all
bills ordered a third reading be read a
third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it be to meet Thursday April 11th
at 10:00
a.m. the question is on the third
reading motion are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose n the eyes have it the
motion is
adopted house recognizes a clerk for an
announcement thank you Mr Speaker a
couple of quick announcements if you
would
please this is an important announcement
for not just you members but for anybody
watching materials specific specifically
lobbying pamphlets handouts Etc are not
to be left in the anti- rooms of the
House of Representatives they can be
passed out outside but they are not to
be left on tables without explicit
permission of the speaker of the
house last yesterday we had two new
members swear in when I went to walk
them to their new seats there was a pile
of candy rappers on the floor behind
somebody's seat so please make sure
follow the leave no Trace principles
take it in take it out with you next
this is a very important announcement on
behalf of the Christa mlli uh Memorial
state house um uh commission tomorrow
morning there will be an announcement
from the governor's office about an Arts
competition from for all students across
the state of New Hampshire please pay
attention to that so that students in
your districts can participate lastly
our next session day April 11th we will
celebrate the Fantastic return of tartan
day please wear your GL thank
you representative hosman moves at the
house stand and recess for the purpose
of introduction of bills and roll build
Amendment roll bills report vacate
motion receiving messages are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I those oppos
nay the eyes have it the house is in
recess until Thursday April 11th 2024 at
a.m.
for